niort quart de finale entre haïti et par
am qui ont gagné hier la prod châssis du
coup et qui ont l'air de bien se marrer
en france en ce prématurément l'air de
rigoler puis vont s'affronter pendant
quatre heures quand même ça va être un
peu long après nous on a de la chance on
va pas suivre tout le match on va suer
jusqu'à 19h 19h30 et après on ira se
préparer pour pour la pourpre vladan
fait donc sûrement jusqu'à white 19h30
on va on va aller jusqu'à 19h30 dans ce
match on va suivre pendant deux heures
et demie et on n'en suivra que 2 sur 4
des quarts de finale de ce pitch est
junior parce que parce que ça suffit
travail je sais pas pourquoi en fait on
pourrait suivre dès 4 mais parce que
parce que j'ai pas envie de suivre les
quatre pour faire simple on pourrait le
faire mais on ne va pas le faire après
je pense pas que vous allez forcément
très envie non plus
de tous les suivre du pouvoir ont fait 2
on va faire celui là est un autre comme
je vous le disais et après et après on
fera les demi finales et la finale en
espérant que ce soit bien j'attends que
les gens qui avaient un peu dans chat
salut à edgar bg skn il souhaite bonne
chance ils ont gagné hier à la prod chez
slick bravo à eux
attendez je vais être un téléphone
salut ah ben ça lui à flot bibi
coquelles après un parti qui est lancé
je sais pas encore de quel côté ils ont
mis les calmes sur le truc officielle
donc j'ai mis dans ce sens cela me fera
peut être inversée bon après je vous
préviens le match je le regarde
tranquille c'est pas la ja beau il ya
beaucoup de live c'est pas non plus le
match qu'on attend d'eux plus est un
match sympa mais je veux dire par là que
voilà c'est sympa sans non plus sans non
plus sans non plus être ouvre toi tu
vois j'aime pas du tout ce design par
rapport à la cam
ça l'a fait d'être vraiment bas c'est
vraiment là on peut importe mais coup je
re règle je vous sais système accueille
ces trois hic je sais pas lequel des
deux est le plus fort mike est un peu
plus des lots mais parham voyait
peut-être taille qu'un peu plus fort sur
dans ce dans ce format là mais mon
parham doit être plus fort en partie
donc du coup c'est difficile à dire il
salua max bac et salué un max bac
si vous avez suivi hier le match jeu de
chacun même temps que tout soit bon je
passerais suivi hier le match de pro de
chez sig
qu'est ce que ça donne pour l'instant
bahia 001 ça vient d'eux ça vient de
démarrer
donc pour le moment j'ai envie de dire
il t'arrive au tout début du match et
salue leur tige et c'est pour le monde
arrive au tout début début début du
match et encore personne sur le live
je vérifie juste qui marchent justement
montrent déçus pour la projeter comme en
bas c'était sympa 1 victoire de
l'arménie c'est en combien de partis 104
heures le match ça va jouer pendant
quatre heures donc vous avez le temps
c'est toujours la même chose en fait
hier le mât du coup était intéressant
parce que le format était cool mais
voilà c'est dit il ya toujours ce ce
petit souci de forme en va pas revenir
dessus mais qui fait que voilà c'est pas
surtout la première heure et demie la en
5 + 1 est vraiment pas excitante mais ça
on n'y peut pas grand chose les gars
ouais quatre heures c'est long en fait
c'est très difficile de se projeter sur
un truc de quatre heures qui avancent
petit à petit en fait je suis d'accord
mais voilà c'est le format décidé c'est
la finale avant l'heure dix magnifiques
chaise
non mais ike pour moi il fait partie des
gros favoris mais après on verra
en tout cas il fait il fait souvent très
mal an title tuesday il est régulier au
moins on est sûr que c'est le meilleur
qui gagnera et c'est çà s'est
on est bien sûr au moins alors ses
positions le fourrage de est très fort
c'est pour ça qu'il fait tour 8 pour
faire re 5 passes qui contrôle trop de
cases importante en fait regarder les
blancs là qui contrôlent beaucoup de
cases
donc s'ils réussissent à rentrer à l'ale
dame ils vont faire mal en fait c'est
pour ça qu'on a absolument besoin de
jouer 5 avec les noirs pour couper le
foie h2 en fait et prendre le centre au
passage est-ce que je trime l'es4 alors
non parce que ce soir en fait on à la
master class avec vlad qui était prévu
depuis longtemps en fait bas que j'ai
essayer de prévoir avec nous depuis
longtemps avec vlad c'est pas facile de
trouver des créneaux mai
du coup d'air je vais écrire abattoirs
pour le truc mais du coup en fait ben on
nous a annoncé que le match il était
aujourd'hui samedi soir quoi il ya eu
encore un changement de dernière minute
et y en a eu beaucoup
donc du coup
du coup je vais pas faire tout le match
après j'aurais pu ne pas le faire du
tout en fait d'ailleurs mais bon j'en
ferais pas un autre en fait du coup
pendant la semaine
parce que ça m'arrangeait plus de faire
celui-là est pas en faire un autre parce
que je me suis mis d'accord
du coup pour pas qu'on commente tous les
matchs de ce pitch est junior en
français dans le sens où il y en a et on
a vraiment beaucoup trop en fait là mon
goût un après c'est moi en tant qu' en
tant que commentateur
c'est vraiment c'est trop long et dans
le temps aidant et dans le nombre de
matchs donc j'ai juste dit les gars tant
pis tant pis pour les rémunérations quoi
mais honnêtement c'est enfin au bout
d'un moment c'est juste trop en fait ça
je vais faire une overdose d'échec donc
on va regarder ces petits match
tranquille mais mais voilà ça ça fait ça
fait un peu beaucoup
donc là c'est pas mal ce qu'il fait avec
les noirs il a réussi à prendre le
centre a coupé le fou de cases blanches
et a finalement les blancs vont pas
réussir à ouvrir l'oeil dame ça se passe
plutôt correctement pour les noirs et
les blancs il aurait adoré réussir à
ouvrir une colonne et à rentrer avec les
tours surtout la colonne b du coup mais
là c'est pas simple faute est réfugié à
1 tout comme ses quatre ici c'est parce
qu'il vient de jouer mais ça paiera 6
donc par am qui a quand même dominé la
sur les derniers coups donc haye
comparable à ces quarts de finale de ce
pitch est junior et ça doit être sympa
commenté hier baroin hier c'était sympa
hier c'était sympa pour l'apn ben le
match était cool et c'était intéressant
bah c'est tout c'est tout de suite
honnêtement c'est de suite différent
quand tu commentes un event sympa c'est
ça sans y ait beaucoup plus de monde on
est monté à 650 700 alors que on s'est
tapé tellement de mauvais match que ça
fait évidemment baisser les audiences
c'est toujours pareil en fait hein c'est
qu'à force de faire des événements pas
très excitant les gens viennent moins
regardés on a quand même réussi à monter
à 650 ce qui est ce qui est plutôt sympa
donc il y avait beaucoup plus de monde
hier que les autres jours parce que le
contenu était simplement plus
intéressant à regarder
ce qui fait la diff 1 et salue wspa là
et ces deux joueurs ont d'ailleurs
et là il va il va réussir à jouer tour 1
et à s'en prendre aux pions à 7 donc il
a réussi à houdain m'adresser la même
idée à se recréer du jeu sur le pion à
renault hier c'était un c'est un match
sympa c'est un match sympa
malheureusement n'a pas été super suivi
dans les autres langues mais bon au
moins nous on s'est fait plaise que ceux
qui l'ont vue sont fait plaisir en la
maintenant avec les blancs il va réussir
envoyé pur il a réussi à faire ce qu'il
fallait en fait à faire jouer le x h 2
et à faire jouer à faire parler d'elle
dame fait toutes les pièces blanches
sont placés pour jouer à zelda mais il
n'y a pas de jeu à l'endroit où les
pièces noir pourrait dominer quoi il est
un peu en retard genre c'est six
cavaliers 5 c7 le pion il avance un peu
trop vite
il ya trop d'harmonie côté blanc
maintenant au nom hier c'était vraiment
sympa je sais pas qui a vu leur lit
salut à toi ça lui attachait qui hier
c'était vraiment très cool c'est
vraiment dommage que ce soit que que dès
que des beaux matchs des baux even comme
hier finalement soit entre la cde
beaucoup d'événements inintéressant quoi
et je trouve je trouve vraiment ça
dommage je trouve vraiment ça dommage
mais bon c'est comme ça c'est pas moi
qui décide de la programmation
malheureusement la salle arc
pas pour les noirs ouais ça perd une
pièce juste après un petit potentiel
arnaque un peut-être des tours prend à
cet intermédiaire parce que moi-même
surprend à cette dame prend 1,7 pour
penser 5 france et 5 france et cinq
dames français 5 donc les blancs vont
avoir une pièce de plus il en est qui va
rater la master class de vlad aux
seychelles berly ah ouais ça va vraiment
être cool en plus vlad qui va montrer
ses meilleures parties d'attac
ça va être sympa donc haye qui va gagner
la première game
j'en suis maintenant assez sûr à rennes
ont raté raté sa berline ça être la
déception nada
j'ai pas mis sur icloud âmes à 50 jours
non parce qu'elle était c'était plus
pour du live
guillaume la deuxième master class de
mur parce mur tastet plus et cgg un peu
revenu en redif c'était c'était plus
plus pour pourvoir en live et la ja foot
pro f
aya pas fait recette par l'amf pour les
recettes qu'ils menacent s'ils avaient
échec ouais mais bon toute façon c'est
gagnant ivoire dame prend bk tout dame
sait qu'à tout prendre quatre ça c'est
vraiment terminé de chez terminé ça peut
s'abandonner après généralement tu la
joues encore un tout petit peu d'accord
sur wager de il veut damev trois échecs
et suroît géant dames f3 dame prend b4
il veut d'âme des uns je pense
ce que c'est son idée il va sûrement
faire dame f3 ici
il va sûrement faire d'un f3 mais sur
quoi on pourra répondre four b3 et tout
bloquer donc il a fait b3 donc là il
n'ya pas fou prend f7 évidemment puisque
la dame est protégé dam des quatre bien
joué et fois deux ils couvrent il va
pouvoir gagner le pion b2 mais c'est
bien joué de la part de parra main ils
défendent vraiment très bien il va faire
dame prend b2 dame prend h3 et sûrement
dame b 8 dames f4 ouais bah ouais quand
la dame est en effet 4 tu touches plus à
rien maintenant l'idée fous ces quatre
fois f1 ou dame price est évidemment un
match tu vas faire g5 ou prises et sur
pions prend dame g5 ouais c'est bien
joué et fou au 6 mai c'est fini c'est
dead faut aussi jouer ça va gagner le
pion à f5 et sa force des changes des
dames quasiment parce que sa menace
d'armes 3f 5h échec donc première
victoire pour le joueur arméniens qui
mène 1 0
il a il a assez bien joué 1
alors c'est une petite berlinois je
regardais le chat pendant l'ouverture
mais on reconnaît la finale de la
berlinoise ike qui en a joué qui a joué
sa fière aussi en process league
ils sont jeunes comment ils sont jeunes
à quel point ben ils ont la vingtaine
ils ont ils ont la petite vingtaine ces
deux joueurs qui ne seront pas top 10
mondial ça on peut le savoir par am qui
a dans un moment a eu un gros rush
voulait passer au dessus de 2007 mais là
il marque vraiment le pas il lui il lui
a manqué un peu pour arriver à 27,50 tu
penses pas qu'il puisse y arriver et ike
qui semble largement préféré le jeu en
blitz que le jeu en partie longue
donc ça c'est un peu le même problème
que moi en fait c'est un gros défaut
face un gros défaut si tu as de bons en
longue c'est dur quand tu aimes pas
autant quoi ce que tu es face à des gens
qui adorent les parties longues et toi
tu préfères les blitz et les parties
rapides et c'est vraiment très
handicapant arrivé à un certain âge à
certains niveaux en fait donc du coup
ces deux joueurs qui font pas partie du
top mondial mais ike qui qui est un des
huit soeurs très dangereux mais salut
des sas au séga
il va prendre prend dans ses trois donc
toujours pareil un set cette berlinoise
les noirs vont essayer de faire un
blocus sur cases blanches et la
germanique la joue un tour des huit qu
est le plus fort sur le papier
dur à dire ninja mais dans ce format
internet blitz série
je pense qu'un peu plus fort sauf le
bullet chez pas 3059 et maintenance et
c'est sérail qu'il a de très bons
résultats en title tueuse et si vous
suivez donc il doit être légèrement plus
fort après en longues se serait pas ram
et salua youn mi llion mickey un petit
snowflake la question sur les tours j'ai
6 ans fait mais tu peux te prendre dh 5
était obligé de repartir mais ce que le
tueur est moins bien place en h 5 ou pas
c'est une question il ya aussi des rois
e71 qui peuvent être jouées ou des rois
et fuite pour ramener la tour en 8es
mois contre
écoute si je perds 20 à 3 ou 20 à 4 je
suis content contre ces deux joueurs ils
sont vraiment beaucoup plus fort que moi
que ce soit que ce soit par amour ou ike
en gros et si je prends si je prend 9
ainsi je prends 9,1 on va dire je suis
content ces trois gratos
si tu prends ces trois peut-être détour
des 3 es tu te fais doubler rapidos mais
ça et qu'il était peut-être prenable
c'était peut-être joué à bouaké en
france et 3 je pense à terminer le
développement perso ça fait un peu peur
mais oui c'était peut-être faisable
là il va mettre la tour en f3 sûrement
est ce que ces trois prix pouvait faire
ses 4es à et déloger le cavalier alors
qu'est ce qu'il va faire avec les blancs
parfois c4 est quand même une idée
puisque sa triple les pions et quand tu
regardes la position en fait c'est les
noirs qui répondent un pion de plus ce
genre matériellement mais tu as
l'impression que c'est les blancs qui
ont un pion de plus ce que c'est eux qui
peuvent se créer un pion passer cette
situation assez marrante bon c4 après
c'est pas forcément le coup mais ça ça
peut être marrant le pion c4 obstrue la
case c4 pour le fou et d'un autre côté
les noirs avec leurs pions triplé ils
sont pas très beau en cas il a échangé
prix en hausse 6 et g4 alors il n'y a
pas tout reprend h4 qui à tour et fuit 3
au 7 tours fc est mat et l'idée ça doit
être d'essayer de faire h 5 g 5 h 6 pour
créer un pion pas ses protégés par le
phocéen
c'est pas facile à arrêter parce que
j'ai six t'as pas envie de ça ça bloque
son cavalier si la tour en 36 carlib et
6 qui haïssez 5 je sais pas kelly sky c4
pardon pour essayer d'attaquer ça et ça
mais bon après après h5 g5 y aura
peut-être des cavaliers sept cavaliers
f5 mais il peut y avoir des tours fc est
de l'autre côté c'est pas évident à
jouer pour les noirs je trouve mais il
doit y avoir un coup il fait ses 5 h 5
d'accord mais ce que veut faire à 5 des
cas de bouffe bouffe bout faire bouffer
du cavale non il part avec son rang
bessette
ben je sais pas comment il devait jouer
il paraissait bien enfermé c'est
peut-être bien joué mais je sais pas
j'ai l'impression que les blancs vont
réussir un jour à faire ça avec le plus
rage sera hyper fort j'aurais aimé avoir
le roi pour le défendre
mais c'est vrai qu'il était un peu en
bouteille est allé pas facile celle là
joué pour les noirs mais c'est jamais
été facile à finir avec les blancs non
plus parce qu'un jour tu peux avoir un
gros contre jeu de l'autre côté et ça
peut devenir dangereux cc des positions
clairement moi j'ai enfin on a toujours
l'impression que les blancs sont
vraiment bien et d'art kasparov ne
croyait pas du tout en cette variante là
pour les noirs même si l'ordinateur a
montré que ça tenait mais tu as toujours
à être l'impression d'être au rupteur
avec les noirs et finalement parfois tu
as dû contre jeux qui arrivent tout d'un
coup à la dame
c'est intéressant fait tout rêve c'est
de bouffer vii bouffer vii pour la
tempête s'est efforcé et tour g8 donc
pas quand même l'impression avec les
blancs cta une tour 7e est un pion passé
qui se dessine mais y'a qu'à y prend ses
3 et menaces cavale yeux de d'ailleurs
au passage
donc faut faire un coup droit alors
peut-être sur f1 d'ailleurs
il le met en g2 à oui d'accord il veut
il veut il veut a monté le roi c'est
assez logique et les noirs qui vont
sûrement joué un coup comme à 5 avec idb
cas de bouffe bouffer envoyé le pion à
quand même à 5 g 6b caprice prise h6
prise
j'essaie 3,8
ouais ça peut être dur cavalli eux deux
et cavaliers des quatre d'accord donc
elle a eu envie de revenir rapidos avec
son cavalier au centre maintenant est-ce
qu'on peut tenter fou prend puis on
prend et monte le roi il fait g6
ouais c'était de façon un coup à faire
sur cavaliers f5 de toute façon il avoue
prend ses 5 fu j'ai cinq échecs croise
et 8
c'est un peu forcé un roi 8 y avait 300
on prend et on pensait cette a7 et un
problème sur la huitième et maintenant b
4 x 5 et b4 est peut-être des cadres
étaient plus précis puisque sur b4 à 4
du coup à 5 et un coûts superflus b4 le
truc ce que keira des f-5 qui tient la
baraque alors j'imagine qu'il réfléchit
à des a4 sait qu'à tout reprend pions
prend au roi prend b3 puis on prend
pions prend fou c'est un mais je crois
que le roi va pas suffire
c'est fou c'est indirect ils protègent
ils bloquent les pions indus qui va
avoir à 4 il fait autour des 8
si ce qui peut être un coup ici c'est
hyper compliqué pions pranger 7 ya
peut-être tour des quatre échecs crois
bouger sur touré futur accueil pranger
cette paroisse bouge avant et tour
descartes échec après il ya tout reprend
f5 qui est toujours un coup candidats
avec prise prise harry fait ça moi ce
que j'avais vu c'était ça ça et ça et
surtout reif 8 tours des quatre
étrangers 7 mai a peut-être tout reprend
f5 qui ont point f 5 3 points f5 h5 3g
6h 4 wife 7h 3g 8 d'am-dam roi prend à
la hache de forêt fairway faudrait faire
flouer 4 avant mais à les pions qui part
de l'autre côté c'est assez compliqué
les gains parce qu'il ya des pions pas
céder et des choses à faire valoir des
deux côtés c'est vraiment complexe parce
que c'est avec les noirs ils peuvent se
retrouver avec h et a passé ce qui peut
être hyper fort en fait même si un fou
de plus donc prise
j'imagine qu'il va faire cb j'imagine
avec l'idée à 4 à 3
le pion béquille à b4 qui est utile
parce qu'ils protègent mais même s'il
puis arrivant à deux il y aura foule b2
qui défendra
après sur g7 est aussi cavalier prendre
tout reprend et tour d un qui peut
exister pour envoyer le pion à royat il
ya beaucoup de choses à faire valoir
pour les noirs les c'est ce que je vous
disais en fait on a l'impression depuis
tout à l'heure qu'il était mal à ajka
mais maintenant il a les pions passé
c'est exactement la variante qu'on a vue
qui va qui va rentrer il va sûrement
faire à trois mais alors là les gars
wife 6 c'est hyper complexe h5 a alors
dit que maintenant c'est les blancs qui
sont gagnants après eux 6 à 2 sous b 2 h
4 e set tour 8 3 f c'est 3,17 g8 dame
prise prises l'uruguay c'est non attends
cca
c'est très dur a le réflexe serait de
faire h4 ici quand même il a fait roi
bessette
cette tour d un ouais d'accord c'est
qu'il y avait un problème dans la
variante sûrement bon là c'est sûr que
c'est fini parce que il ya deux dames et
il est pas parti colonnes et ça va
gagner bons l'évaluation s'est emballée
des deux côtés moi j'essaie de
comprendre la partie en la regardant
mais sa santé que ça pouvait tourner
avec les pions passé de partout cette
finale
a été intéressante et c'est par am qui
en sort victorieux et donc qui égalise
on peut avoir la barre des vals je
trouve que ça ramollit le bulbe la barre
des vals nuage 9
du coup on va essayer de rester avec le
bulbe intacte c'est un quart de finale
dd je suis déjà mouvement on va essayer
de te durcir nuage
c'est vrai que c'est parti un peu dans
tous les sens dans la partie précédente
on va essayer de se durcir le bulbe
c'est quand même bien de se durcir le
bulbe
et salue grand maître gims pourquoi pas
kadhafi ça vend bien et peut-être un
problème avec fou prend 1,6 est il fou
c'est un quand même qui veille au grain
voilà on va avoir cette position
assortie de l'ouverture dans ce grand bi
dames avec le classique fou bessette
contre le centre blanc alors se durcir
le bulbe est non mais c'est important
d'avoir un bulbe dur quoi moi je suis
contre le fait d'avoir la barre
d'évaluation non-stop après je sais que
maintenant même chaise comme en anglais
le 20 commentent avec avec la barre
d'évaluation non-stop affiché à l'écran
moi je trouve que les gens après même
même mois en fait on est là tout le
temps à regarder la barre la barre la
barre c'est s'est passé relou surtout
qu'il ya beaucoup de retournements de
situation d'autant plus en blitz là on
peut faire un plan marrant avec les
blancs avec un fouet aux caprices prises
et tour des 3 essayé de faire passer les
tours ça peut représenter un danger
un cri fouka tg3 et de l'ordre et
cachent quatre dames prend écailles g5
j'imagine et peut-être h5 avancer ses
pions proche du roi
ces cinq d'accord ça échange ça échange
ça échange larroy g2 me donne envie
c'est pas par principe je n'aime pas
rester en face et ça protège le cavalier
après il ya aussi h4 évidemment c'était
dans son plan de base
mayroy g2 j'aime bien tu donnes un peu
le tra l'adversaire celui force a montré
ses intentions et enlève ton roi h4
aussi un cd deux coups que tu as envie
de faire
d'ailleurs dans les deux dans les deux
sens un ils peuvent être joués il a fait
hk 3g 2
non est ici
il fait j'ai 4ème taille peut essayer de
jouer avec h5 peut-être et faire la
grosse prise des spasmes et la plus
assez de matériel pour attaquer sur case
blanche qui lui manque le fou mais si tu
joues g5 h5 faut faire gaffe parce qu'un
jour ses pions sur noir peuvent devenir
très faible c'est ce qui fait mais c'est
à double tranchant
ça prend beaucoup d espaces devant le
roi adverse ça c'est sûr mais d'un autre
côté un jour dans une finale il peut y
avoir un fou et f2 fois h4 ou g5 et
d'ailleurs il joue avec g6 d'accord son
idée c'est sûr puis on prendra mener un
quart ayant g5 et ça c'est assez logique
comme idée je dirais que c'est plutôt
bien joué personnellement l'idée de se
gagner 7 4 et 5 est plutôt intéressante
par ailleurs de bien chanter ouais il a
mis à chanter pendant les matches je
rappelle que ces deux joueurs ont gagné
la prothèse sigir avec l'équipe de
l'arménie face face aux américains qui
semblait avoir une grosse armada mais
qui n'ont rien pu faire face à la
puissance de l'arménie
ils hésitent à prendre les trojans de
feuilla way final trois et demi sur
quatre il a fait un gros match
les arméniens qui sont vraiment très
dangereux dans ce format qu'il a pris
prix et d'un la fuite maintenant une
idée a surtout reprend ses huit attend
truc je n'arrive pas à comprendre ce qui
laisse le pion d'accord oui d'accord ils
attaquent f2 mais donc on peut peut-être
prendre prendre prendre et prendre et on
prendra là à la fin et on fera dame
prend ça gagne peut-être en fait ça tout
reprend il peut pas faire dame prend f2c
cloud est donc tout reprend tout reprend
ses 5
il peut pas prendre f2 il ya plus le fou
cavaliers prend 1,6 à à son idée ces
dames des cinq ici d'accord j'ai compris
donc il a pris en c5 prix c'est ça qui
va prendre six maintenant à d'accord
c'était pour empêcher le dam des cinq as
mais il peut faire maintenant à tour des
huit maintenant il va prendre de la dame
mais y aura peut-être dame pranger 6 mai
normalement non non ça tu rentre pas là
dedans si rentrer là dedans
bon tout reprend des huit impossible
quel point aussi ce qui est prompt des
huit dames pranger 6 donc il doit faire
dame prend et sur quoi il y aura d'un
projet 6
qui menace
mais cette dame h5 et tout le rsa gagne
peut-être pour pourra y que ça c'est
assez joli puisque dame hockey et on
prend des buts on va vraiment partir du
principe que ça perd donc d'apprendre un
projet 6 admettons dan des cinq échecs
f3 dam des deux rois h trois essais les
blancs qui vont envoyer les échecs en
premier et sur dame 8 il doit vouloir
damage c3 et fuite damage suis trop
cette dame j'essaie trois des huit
cavaliers à vii droit c'est cette cavale
et des six dames 17 prend 17 prend 17
france et 8 france et 8 et puis en plus
dans la finale de pions très fort un
très bien joué de la part de ait là le
h5 g5 un g6 bas donc il prend la tour
mais il se dit que sa meilleure chance
et d'aller faire nul dans cette finale
de deux dames et ces finales dames avec
un pion - à d'un projet si c'est adam
des cinq encore ouais mais bon on peut
faire dame ces quatre dames c'est 5
alors ouais mais peut-être il va prendre
h4 alors peut-être 6 ie6 jouer il arrive
à la même conclusion que moi avec le
même cheminement tu pense d'abord adam g
6 puis adams et 4 dames c5 puis aussi ce
qui menace d'alger 6 en fait avec le
pion qui sera protégé donc damien 8 a
maintenant tu peux pas eu cette île roi
ici
qu'est ce que tu vas avoir alors
peut-être dan des 5,3 g iii d'accord moi
j'ai trois c'est pas mal ouais
martirossian il a une vraie gueule
d'acteur oui je suis d'accord il
pourrait il pourrait vraiment jouer un
méchant il a il a vraiment une tête
d'acteur way as tu peux peut-être faire
roi f4 et suroît recettes d'anne 17 3e 6
dames 4 wife cette prise prise et la
finale est gagnante puisque le roi est
avancé ça illustre bien l'importance de
l'avancé à mais il ya peut-être g5
fouinait sq pour créer le pion pas ch de
peut-être faut faire rager 5 3 f 7 et f4
ces quatre à cinq et tu gagnes quand il
a fait dame c4
donc sur dame cette île à damas six seul
coup pour défendre les deux pions du
coup c'est dame c8 protège les deux
pions et garde un oeil sur six ça défend
bien un côté côté parham truc c'est que
si tu donnes un pion après toutes les
finales droits sont gagnantes donc c'est
c'est très problématique
non mais ike en vrai ils auraient une
bonne tête ya pas de 3,6 ici juste je le
verrais bien joué le rôle d'un gangster
à l'ancienne mais gangster falun gong
star gentil c'est pas le mot mais tu
vois là enril tu as il aurait pas une
tête de tony montana quoi il aurait plus
une tête de henry lé pour ceux qui ont
vu des affranchis d'accord donc là il
veut peut-être un dame 17 un jour la
question c'est geagea qui peut faire à 6
et maintenant la haye adam 17 c sur la
saynète parce que sur wells issia damev
7 et sur rv à effia damian dame f7 aussi
donc il reprend le lead bien joué de la
part de ike qui fait son match un pour
le moins les petites françaises
il retourne pas dans la berlinoise % est
pas si mal joué mais il rentre dans une
win over
ici apparemment hélène vente avec b4 ses
béquilles a et b cinq ans après c'est
pas mon répertoire
il a fait dame g4
donc certes winger le pingouin en tout
cas on est bien d'accord qu'il a une
il a une tête de gangsters pas trop
méchant dans un fil non c'est parce
qu'il a eu le nez cassé je pense je
pourrais lui demander mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il a eu le nez cassé
parce que ce sac loison nasale elle a
pas l'air elle a pas l'air droite et
saluer les ocz est ce jeu je pense qu'il
s'est fait casser le nez où il a fait de
la boxe way clairement mais il a l'air
sympa en fait ça qui est pas mal c'est
qu'il a son nez cassé il a un peu un peu
way dans l'imaginaire peut-être une tête
de ritalin peut dans un certain sens ce
genre [ __ ] [ __ ] rouscoff je sais pas
trop comment expliquer il est un peu à
la croisée des chemins et ouais donc qui
en fait il a ce mélange des deux choses
qui font qu'il a way vraiment une bonne
ni bonne tête d'acteur ouais c'est pas à
l'époque elle choquante dahouët ça
ressemble un petit peu la partie donnée
pour peut-être concède là l'ex contre
alex enhco
la position française vraiment toujours
là hyper dangereux pour les noirs je les
joue bien avec les blancs généralement
gers en catalan initiative genre là
juste un coup comme tour des 1 pour se
mettre en face de la dame est préparée
peut-être un transfert de la tour me
fait peur
ouais ça et qu'il aussi sur le fauteuil
qui donne qui donne l'impression des
films de gangsters années soixante dix
on va dire je dirais
corleone non plus hein soyons très
sérieux mais je pense que c'est le
décalage entre eux entre sa terre que ça
donne et le côté dans le faciès et dans
le visage de gars super sympa je pas tu
as l'impression que c'est vraiment un
gars sympa c'est ça qui est marrant il
ressemble plus à fredo corléonais ray
ouais il ressemble plus à fredo vrai
en tout cas oui je suis 100% d'accord
avec vous il a ignoré une tête d'acteur
ouais ouais haye que c'est par am c'est
le contraire de ike ouais mais l'air
très sympa ou s'il faut aller là
franchement les deux gars et aussi comme
je vous disais avant le match ils
rigolaient ensemble et tout pour après
jouer dans la même équipe ils doivent
être contents de leur victoire hier mais
ils ont je pense ces deux gars vraiment
sympa ça a l'air d'être deux gars de
gars très cool et il ay là il un logo
sur son tee shirt d'un site internet
eyes que j'essaierai de lire tout à
l'heure on n'arrive pas bien à voir mais
quand il se lève juste à être voulu lire
donc le problème de ces françaises que
j'aime pas avec les noirs quand ça se
passe comme ça c'est que tu as
l'impression d'être tellement galère
avec ta tour ses huit qu'elle jouera
jamais m'apprête à la case f5 pour le
cavalier tu peux trouver du jeu mais qui
à la casse c'est 6 rue cavalier blanc
champion que les pièces blanches sont
juste mieux organisé il ya plus d espace
à tout âge
c'est peut-être par à jouer après
attention quand on prend ces cinq ont
obligé de reprendre du pillon mais ça
semble pas poser problème juste réaction
à cette aussi un qui peut qui peut être
en l'air faut se méfier
ouais c'est avec les north a pas de
tourner ici c'est toujours dame prend h5
quand même donc pour le mans avec les
plantes est quand même assez tranquille
tu peux vouloir prendre en d5 prendre
des 5 eca et des cas pour qui ces six je
partirai pour ça perso mais a peut-être
un cavalier e 4 ouais j'aurais pu me
faire piéger par ce truc là ça j'aurais
pu largement me faire piéger le carioca
j'aurais pu ne pas le voir sur puis on
prend des cinq je considère c'est très
bien pour les blancs il ya plus de cases
f5 on va installer un cavalier en d4 un
jour on va être bien donc je considérais
qu'il prend des 5 et le coup sûr c'est
qu'à de façon cavalière paraît avoir
visé la case la case f5 évoquions prend
il me fait mentir qui des quatre et
c'est exactement ce à quoi je pensais
dame 17
est-ce que c'est une opportunité pour
ces quatre parce que sur pied on prend
alors accueilli 6,6 et on pourra faire
une double attaque sur la dame et le
cavalier ça pourrait être le cas mais il
joue ses quatre d'ailleurs ça pouvait
être le cas les gars
et ça a été jouée ce c4 après on peut
aussi avec les noirs et imaginer des
tours g6 d'un taux d'emprunt et des
damage 3 mai faudra faire gaffe à des
dames pranger 6 dont il fait tout re 8
emprise tour j'ai six dames h5 ya pas
d'un match croyais à damas g6 et d'amd 5
donc ils menacent matongé 2 me sur un
pion c'est bien ses pions de plus pour
parham écart élèves trois blocs le mat
lecavalier protégé par la dame et on
attaque la dame donc la dame va se
barrer sûrement way en c4 mais là ça
peut échanger et prendre ici maintenant
et rentrer sur la 7ème rsa paraît
difficile
ça paraît difficile maintenant là
clairement clairement pas ramer mieux
après ça peut se retourner en blitz
mais il ya déjà un pion de plus il peut
y en avoir un deuxième les tours qui
rentre ça paraît difficile pour pour ike
ici comme position après il mène au
score donc ce serait une égalisation le
match pour le moment et indécis on a 45
minutes de jeu quasiment donc on va
arriver à la moitié de la cadence
son idée sur dame france et être carré
les g5 et surtout rachid d'un rêve 7
ouais ça fait mal donc peut-être faut
jouer b prend mais après tout reprend à
s'être le pion b va être super fort il
commence par tourage 6 adacore il veut
il veut pas qu'ils aient de cavaliers g5
double attaque
et maintenant il va prendre en c5
c'est quand même des sacrés des penseurs
et les gars
ça défend quand même bien parce que la
position est très difficile et il te
trouvent des pièges de partout ils
comprennent les les menace adverse ça
joue vraiment très bien donc il blindes
le pion à vii
une dame des 4
y'a pas d'un pro b 5 à tour prend 1,7 du
coup à la crème deux pions de plus déjà
pour les blancs parham qui a peut-être
perdu sa connexion là alors en tout cas
il ya plus la caméra c'est problématique
là pour pour par am c'est pas trop ce
qui s'est passé on l'a vu toucher
quelque chose à ses revenus le plus
important ce qu'ils soient restés
connectés à cheste comme lé tour ses 8
ans l'attend g6 pas mal place elle
bloque les pions elle va pouvoir les
verbes et 6 donc là l'idée de ax et
qu'il a deux pions - mais il a le
contrôle jeu avec le pion c est y avait
cinq en l'air alors ses quatre tours f
cette c3 peut-être mais il y aura
cavalier e 1 et sur ses deux pieds
france et 2 aya peut-être tour c'est
cette aussi plus simple encore mais je
pensais qu'ils auraient lieu un perso
avec l'idée de se sacrifier ouais c'est
ce qu'ils jouent mais tout reprend baies
5.25 tour b 1
peut-être il ya du contre eux je rouages
de tours eu un ton g5 à sur ces deux
tours g73 ici il va vouloir faire 1 h 6
pour menacer maths et là il va faire
rage 6 am et la tourache un échec encore
oh la la la défense et f4 et c'est un
pardon et d'un f4 roitg 3 alors tour ces
trois ça paraît logique
il fait dame f5 c'est logique aussi
enfin là après tout est logique tour c4
budam pro f devrait tour c4 c'est
logique f4 dame point f 4 3 ici d'un
match 4 matt a laissé faire tourner par
am as est terrible c'est terrible il
devait être gagnant
mais l'échec en achat
ouais suroît g3 y aurait eu tout reprend
1 h 6 qu'est ce qu'il a fait comme
conneries j'en sais rien mais il était
il était gagnant c'est sûr pendant
longtemps parra mais il se retourne et
ça fait 3 pour pour ike et ike qui
montrent pourquoi il est si fort pendant
ses cadences
il défend terriblement bien ike et salue
antonymes 49 dans le chat c'est un
excellent un excellent marlou et c'est
vrai que sas dans ce genre de match en
fait ces petites parties elles font
vraiment une énorme différence parce
qu'il suffit que tu tarnac deux parties
comme ça que tu te fasses jamais
arnaquer est en réalité le 2-2 ça fait
trois ans tu le fais une deuxième fois
au lieu de 3,2 ça fera ça fera 4 1 et au
final battu fin tu auras trois points
d'avance quoi et ça fera la différence
est aussi moralement et mentalement
c'est difficile là pour parham parce que
si permanent avec les noirs il se
retrouve à moins 3 sans avoir vraiment
eu l'impression d'être dominés et c'est
dans des matches en fait avoir cette
femme capacité faculté à retourner les
parties cc c'est vraiment très important
donc
ding dong bang
les noirs qui ont joué à quatre dames
c'est 2
mais là il va y avoir échangé menace de
prendre à nous ils menacent pas de
prendre 30 dams et 8 ce que ses protégés
qui prend 1,5 il va reprendre 5 du
cavale j'imagine et c5 donc sur pions
prend et qui dit gagner f5
il veut prendre en d4 intermédiaire donc
il prend des cats on prend des quatre il
faut il faut et parlons pas prendre des
cinq jeux juste un truc qui m'intrigue
et sur qui prend des cinq arrêts fou
prend il y avait il y avait la tour la
tour eiffe un pardon là excusez moi je
me suis perdu dans cette variante
je me suis perdu j'ai confondu les idées
noires
donc il prend prend 1 et tours b 8
alors maintenant l'idée ça peut être
tout re 1 dames à 2 et commencer à
mettre la pression partout en fait toi
ça paraît sympa la tourelle a plus rien
à faire ici mon damas de au début c'est
toute façon c'est le même plan a est fou
bessette damas est à oui ça c'est bien
joué
ah oui la rentrée sur la 7ème et très
bien joué de la part de miki de ike du
coup
alors maintenant est-ce que dams et 7 et
un coup avec l'idée de de clouer sur la
colonne c
il fait d'amd 6
est ce qu il faut faire gaffe de passe
prendre un damev cet échec à un moment
donné un qui pourrait faire très très
mal ce qui pourrait voir d'un fc 3 h 8
dames f6 fillon prend kiev 7 qui prend
des six c'est pour vous dire parfois
comme on voit les tactiques en fait donc
sert que sur cd / fou pranger déjà cette
idée tactique donc tu devras reprendre
du cheval
et là il a tout repensé et donc sur cd
il aurait fallu prendre en c1 avant mais
après qu'il ait prend des cinq ça
devrait aller donc ils jouent tous
revend avec les blancs et salua willy 10
a fait cavalier e 4 à l'idée peut-être
sur f3 c'est de prendre ces quatre
prendre des cats sur échec et prendre 5
ok donc il fait céder il va y avoir
foule prend des 5 alors maintenant il
faut aussi regarder les danois et
mesdames f7 ya plus d'âme f6 c'est toute
l'idée de cavaliers aux cadres et c'est
pour ça que c'est un terrain peu
important de voir ces tactiques à
l'avance donc d'un fc3a chute on importe
qu'elles coûtent dame menace cavalli
afsset
mais on n'arrive pas à faire mal on peut
faire un nul j'imagine par dame h5 et
encore que avec la qui réfléchissent qui
savait que tu as l'impression que tu
auras un truc genre même tu as envie de
regarder çà çà çà çà çà çà çà il ya ça
il ya ça qui protège à la fin ne
peut-être fou prend fou prend tout
reprend tout reprend dame b cette fougue
et sept cavaliers fc3a bouche qu'elle va
lier prendre tourbe et huit cavaliers
bessette tour bessette on prend aussi ça
peut être genre de variantes qui marche
ça mais il ya beaucoup de lignes annexe
à regarder il fait h4
alors c'est vrai qu'un coup comme tour f
8 menacerait pas la dame
parce que après tout premier set on
aurait cavaliers prend et qui prend des
six j'aime plutôt bien il n'y a pas
d'âme f8 parce qu'il ya dame prend un
cavalier 17 à elle est chiante à jouer
avec les noirs celle là elle est pas
simple à jouer cette position pour
parham il n'a pas foulé cette dame prend
bessette ce ce truc de carélie afsset
qui rôde et très pénible et il commence
à être mal autant adam un futur immédiat
d'un point qui est 17 c'est ce que je
vous disais il a raté ça il y avait trop
de menaces potentielles et il a craqué
hélas hélas on va on va regarder la cam
quand ils seront qui avait 17 ans il a
eu la petite réaction et on voit qu'il a
il a complètement raté
donc là on va pas prendre la tour pour
le moment parce que les deux de façon
sont en l'air donc ça sert à rien
bon il a prise quand même ce qui doit
avoir l'idée de faire un tour b1 et tout
reprend b6 donc oui c'est pour dévier la
tourbe et 8 et la finale va se gagner
aïe que la qui fait un premier écart un
+3 à plus de tueur est encore à portée
de fusil plus +3 pour moi c'est vraiment
le vrai break dance et match vous échec
c'est un peu différent du tennis dans le
sens où la couleur est peut-être un peu
moins importante que le service au
tennis même sûrement et du coup plus 3
c'est le premier vrai break et aussi les
matches sont plus longs du coup a mené 2
0 sur un set qui serait en vingt points
c'est moins important quoi bon il faut
la gagner
alors est ce que fout prend 1,4 puis on
prend 1,4 c'est une manière de gagner
il a commencé par g4 c'est plus logique
et là il fait mal immédiatement pour des
huit chefs et sûrement aller échanger
une paire jay changerait une tour en
faites pas pai a une règle qui dit que
quand tu as deux fois la même pièce et
que l'autre lacune fois tu dois les
échanger
fait mal et le pion qui pourra venir en
h5 aussi pour visser le roi tour c'est
aussi une idée un pour faire tourner
cette parade qui est mal autant ça
devrait faire plus 3 donc il va échanger
les fours haye qui doit vraiment
échanger une paire de tours tours b 5
attention et qu'ils avaient lieu deux
qui menace toujours pénible hambli de
ses cavaliers ils échangent il reste
plus beaucoup de pionsat peut encore
faire nul h5 ouais alors il veut pas se
faire vis et le roi peut-être une tour
peut partir en eaux cette
et tous rêvent cette ouais il plongé
cette tombe et là ça va faire un pion de
plus tout reprend g7 il ya quoi il y
avait lieu de deux mais ça va pas bien
loin et à roye f1 et la tiare watch de
il n'y a pas d'échec avec le cavalier
parce qu'ils en diagonale par rapport au
roi donc maintenant juste un coup deux
tours il va faire rage et si c'est le
seul cours et roy g3 alors il se met
sous le feu de cave a lieu deux
puisqu'il va pas tout reprend eu deux
wild 3 mais là ya plus qu'un échec quand
j'ai un airois ou trois tours prend à
yap à tour j'ai sept tours j'ai un
skieur wife 6 peut-être faire et chaque
échec et repartir avec la tour comme ça
en menacent le cavalier il va faire f3
ici tour h1 cavalia cavaliers h3 ya
paroisse g2 il ya tour g1
il a raté ça donc il doit faire 3e 2 h 3
f 4 il envoie son pion c'est chaud à
cette finale aller par am qui tombent
assez bête ça après c'est dur de trouver
un bon coup mais il tombe
ike a fait des petites fautes tactiques
à la fin mais qui était qui était devant
aïe que c'est son prénom françois jacq
donc on va voir une une bird ou une
hollandaise avec une hollandaise en
premier
eyeka ike qui prend le plus 3 le plus
froid qui fait mal parce que cet été
calme dans la zone dangereuse tout de
suite côté par am se fabrique base
séailles que légèrement en répondant en
tout ça se dit laïc
merci à edgar pour la précision
c'est en parce que j'ai un très bon amis
arméniens à à moscou il s'appelle edgar
aussi du coup j'attends que c'est un
prénom assez répandu en arménie
est-ce que vlad stop 50 à son meilleur
niveau on lui demandera ce soir mais je
pense que oui
madame c7
il va s'en prendre option f4 n'y a pas
d'armé ni en russie oui complètement
mais pour vous dire en russie manquant
les gens ne m'entendais pas encore
parler puisque j'ai un accent assez fort
mais les gens pensaient que j'étais de
faciès qui me prenaient souvent pour un
arménien astérix ou regarder avec grand
nez et les yeux noirs sourcils et les
cheveux noirs en russie c'est
généralement des arméniens qui ont le
faciès que j'ai
kiffer à 4 à 5 c'est pour cela était
pour les arméniens n'ont réservé bien
pour d'autres raisons
mais on m'a souvent pris pour pour un
arménien mais après le prénom est tout
fait que c'était sûr que j'étais par
maignien mais plutôt occidental mais a
donc souvent les gens comprenaient que
j'étais sûrement [ __ ] tout cas
d'origine mais mais du coup mais du coup
elles sont ensemble sans connaître mon
prénom et sans m'avoir parlé les gens
pensaient quasiment tout le temps que je
t'ai arménien bon là peut-être un fast
food et si tu défends tu peux me
défendre par fouquet 4 et essayer de
jouer cavalier contrefout être le fou
j'ai deux un peu bloqué mais il va faire
f5 g4 g5 ça est une partie intéressante
en tout cas c'est une partie plus
importante pour parham que pour ike sky
qui vient de faire son effort il vient
de gagner trois d'affilée même si parham
gagne garde quand même le lead et il va
pouvoir remettre un coup de collier un
peu plus tard en revanche la cie par
annie commence a lâché psychologiquement
et qui laisse encore celle là ça peut
faire mal et groc ce qui est pas mal
c'est qu'ils veulent et c'est fou prend
ses 3 il va reprendre de la dame et il
empêche grand roi qui veut faire le rock
opposés et dire que son attaque est plus
forte
donc il va y avoir meilleur marais pions
côté blanc contre meilleure pièce côté
noir
je préfère les blancs mais pas sûr qu'il
soit vraiment mieux
va voir en tout cas c'est bien joué gros
rock c'est très bons coups il empêche le
grand roque quoi au passage failli force
un peu les recomposer et comme julie
quant à f/5 g4 g5 m6 qui arrive ça va
très vite
qui a rallié 17
il ya plein de matches dans sa cadence
n'est pas une question de nombre de
partis six des as c'est une question de
temps là il reste encore 25 minutes dans
cette cadence puis une heure dans la
cadence suivante plus 30 minutes dans le
1 + 1
d'accord qui avez des sales j'aime bien
en fait je pense qu'un des trucs quand
tu faisais fou prend ces trois dames
france et trois rocs c'était dame prend
1,5 d'un point 5 puis on prend 1,5 et
avait plus cavalier 17.5 maintenant les
gens qui t'ont cavaliers à laterrière
sur une mauvaise case et c'est un
problème
et du coup c'est pour ça qu'il anticipe
tout avec cavaliers 17 et que c'est bien
joué je dirais ike et plus fort
pour moi haye qui est un peu au dessus
déjà il mène au score mais même en
général je le trouve henry ce qui fait
groc maintenant
peut-être il a fait tout france 3 d'un
prendrait trois et sur mon roc
maintenant peut aussi faire my big rock
à foisches 3 qui gêne à l'étude warhawk
es petit tu dois protéger des pions et
envoyé b5 pas simple à 1 comme position
pourquoi parme était chic tient parce
qu'il avait le premier lot de l'équipe
est sûrement qu'en quinze plus dans dix
plus de ils sont plus forts que ike
mais en trois puissants à 5 puissance
des carences qui sont différentes 1
c'est plus rapide
qui a et b 6
d'un prince un qui va sûrement échanger
et tourte des huit peut-être ici il peut
aussi prendre à 4 et surtour 17e' la
cavalier c5 aux cavaliers c5 c'est beau
parce que ça à contrôler deux cas super
importante était pas chassables donc tu
peux prendre à 4 il prend à 4 en tout la
pointe c'est que le tour des sept qui
est le coup thématique marche pas
forcément et cavaliers ccao lecavalier
ses 5 îles et il est monstrueux les gars
tourcoing f7 lecavalier c5 c'est un
monstre
regardez les tentacules il empêche faut
aussi s'il empêche tour 17 il atteint
que quatre mais là je pense qu'il va
faire bref cette 3e set
ouais et le cavalier intouchable et roy
e set
est ce qu'à rallier ses il est juste
impressionnant fait il est incroyable
cavaliers ça y est c'est un truc de ouf
ce cavalier c'est un monument en fait
ngolo quand et mesdames et messieurs
s'il vous plaît ils contrôlent toutes
les cases brassens et un poumon de la
position quoi il est impressionnant ce
cavale j'ai pas si vous sentez à quel
point il est fort
et maintenant soit b6 soit tour des 5
mai tour des cinq peut-être pour essayer
de taper e5
ouais c'est fait ah là là là il peut la
la tour va rentrer en f2 c'est sûr il a
retourné la position s'ils gagnent
celle-là mal de tête pour parham là le +
cats seraient extrêmement mal hein je
vous le dis tout de suite le plus 4 ici
serait terrible parce que là il est en
train de lui faire très très mal aux
échecs quoi est ce qu'il va faire rage 6
pour le moment histoire de fixer sur
blanc peut-être il ya tourache de aussi
qu'il ya un coût évidemment attaque le
fou et se placent b5 aussi une option
ils chassent et peut-être maintenant
tour h2k mais attention à tour f1 tour
eiffe cette attention quand même fou g4
j'imagine un mais il veut rentrer
l'autre tours en d2 et il rentre sur la
deuxième avant que l'hôte rendre sur la
7ème tour des des deux ça va être le
coup je pense qu'un retour d'aidé de fou
fou d1 et tous rêvent de monfreid f5 et
cavaliers ou six du coup pour revenir
vers des quatre reines jouer
qui menace la tour sur vous prend aussi
ses atouts reprend ses deux échecs et on
rase les pions dont g4 haye menace ton
pranger cette faille menaces sur cavani
des katja tout reprend g7 donc il va
devoir attaquer il fait qu'il y ait là
bas non quand même fou prache a très
bien joué faux h7
il garde le fou en vie et oui ton g7
avaient peut-être 3 et fuite
ah ouais faut croire que cette île à
pabu haïk et maintenant tu en prends g7
n'ont pas trop changé sept tours f1 qui
avait lieu trois tours pranger c'est 3 6
tours eu un ouais c'est chaud il ya plus
de temps pour haïti il a raté on apprend
des deux il a gaffé haïk
c'est lui qui gavent cette fois ci est
fou prend des 3 way la ilaha illa
complètement gaffé cavalli g de stella
grosse erreur et par am qui revient à
4-2 important c'est cette partie c'est
de nouveau un petit tournant dans le
match qui doit redonner du baume au
coeur à a par am et s'ils gagnent c'est
là ça change beaucoup de choses
intéressant intéressant donc là un petit
ragots zine spécialité avec les noirs de
param param il mieux joué qu'eux ike
caïques d'ailleurs xavier on nous a dit
alors on a un auditeur arméniens nous a
dit à ips mais parade joue mieux
écoute je sais pas parham je vous mets
en partie longue c'est sûr mais là on
glisse je trouve moi je trouve à ica un
peu un peu plus fort après
après après après chacun son son point
de vue un est ce que c'est les
championnats du monde
non non c'est juste un tournoi amical
sur internet bon la sortie saragoni les
blancs sont quand même un peu mieux il à
l'enfermement du fou ces huit pour le
moment et il va pouvoir prendre en d6
est pressé le pion ses sept plus
agréable à jouer plus agréable à jouer
elle a par am qui a besoin d'eux il a
besoin de se stabiliser à -2 entre
guillemets alors évidemment s'ils
gagnent c'est encore mieux mais il a
besoin de pas retomber dans le de rester
dans le secteur 0 - 2
l'aga d'origine arche concerne quelle
tranche d'âge c'est moins de 21 ans n'a
stahl truc qui est bien que lecavalier à
7,6 qui contrôlent ces huit parfums fait
ce qu'il est horrible mais ils
contrôlent ces 8es il peut parfois
repartir comme ça alors après ce que le
cavalier blanc peut partir comme ça
jusqu'à cinq essais 6 c'est la question
c'est la question qui a aidé de jouer il
va partir en b3 et on a cinq
lorsque saâdane
je sais pas peut-être qu'il a même
refusé la participation parce que c'est
pas forcément très intéressant pour lui
de jouer ce genre de compétition
actuellement franck france j'imagine
il a d'autres objectifs plus importants
il à norwich est cela qui commence dans
une dizaine de jours et il faut qu'il
arrête un petit peu de jouer toutes ces
compétitions sur internet qui semble
avoir fait pour se concentrer sur ce qui
est important c'est à dire bien joué en
partie longue réel donc je sais pas dans
quelle mesure on lui a proposé il a
accepté refusent ou quoi mais dans tous
les cas si on lui a proposé
je pense que le fait dans ces cas là le
fait d'avoir refusé la participation
serait dans tous les cas une bonne
décision parce que j'ai un peu aussi
pour une richesse je pense victoire de
de magnus 1 en vrai le line up est pas
impressionnant puisque a aucun joueur
qui participe aux candidats donc ça veut
dire que il n'ya pas les numéros entre
guillemets 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 et 9 mondiaux
donc ça laisse ça laisse une voix d'or à
magnus a déjà quand ils sont là magnus
est bien au dessus
si en plus ils sont pas là donc là les
blancs sont beaucoup mieux parce qu'ils
contrôlent la seule colonne ouverte de
l'échiquier la colonne c'est le flou
angers 4 est super fort skis à icare ou
non partie longue en réel hikaru il ne
joue que sur internet
ouais je pense aussi que le fait que
fuir ou dja est un peu lâché les
tournois en ligne
ça va payer en partie longue alors je
sais pas que ça a payé tout de suite ou
dans quelques mois ou années
mais je suis sûr que c'est la bonne
décision qui va gagner les candidats
jouent des tours ces trois c'est là
qu'ils étaient là les noirs sont
complètement enfermé un la dame ses
trois tours c1
on va gagner le pion b3 un jour on à la
colonne c'est haye qui domine encore
cette partie et carcela palois de faire
les comptes alors je crois qu'il ya un
genre de ce qu'on appelle les anglais
blue fort c'est qu'il pourrait jouer les
candidats quand même mais ça fait aucun
sens puisque les candidats sont
qualificatifs pour le titre pour pour le
match contre magnus donc ce sera un peu
bizarre donc allé à ce problème pour les
noirs à 7,7 colonnes c'est seule colonne
ouvert tous les tours blanches ont pu
s'installer
c'est un vrai problème pour pour les
noirs je pense moi de 6 magnus il avait
gagné même si gagner les candidats du
coup je vous raconte le deuxième en fait
qui serait qualifié parce que magnus
aurait qualifiés d'office pour le match
en fait ça le qualifierait deux fois
pour le match mais ça le rendrait pas
champions du monde pour autant et toute
façon ça aurait aucun sens qu'un
champion du monde participe au aux
candidats ce serait débile en fait ouais
donc là il va filer la kali a à bien
jouer qui avait b6 qui haïssez 3 am et
athis fait rentrer par derrière un truc
comme ça il pourra pas faire broyer
futur à tour eiffe set mais elle a pas
de réussite pour parham pas sky qui
l'avait pas vu ça
donc toi et b5 à mes cavaliers b6
cavaliers ces trois cavaliers à quatre
sacs avaient lieu deux pardon bref deux
cas et c'est un jeu vient de le voir
maintenant donc c'est un truc de fou in
donc qu'à et b6 kessé 3ème et j'avais vu
ça non non pardon pardon chez l'éditeur
français droite ont réussi ce juge voyez
une autre variante en même temps dans ma
tête c'est ça en fait que je vous disais
la roi ici ça paraît compromis sa perle
à tour et ça ça doit être mieux pour les
blancs quand même ouais la tour va venir
ici et fouet cette fois 5
ça va rentrer là dedans c'est la partie
c'est sûr mais il a de la réussite parce
qu'il avait rien vu
pour échec et on prend jet set mais ça
c'est sûr que c'est mieux pour les
blancs c'est toujours le même problème
de la tour qui arrive pas à rentrer dans
le camp blanc a peut-être tourbe et 4 du
coup la latte on va revenir en à cet âge
et 4 et h 50 et tour à sept qui va
arriver j'en ai fait tour à cette direct
mais à ce que la le cul en arrivant à 4
quand même il va faire g5 du coup
pousser et à jouer pour g6 cela il faut
absolument faire tomber quatre tours ses
quatre tours tour c'est au tour prend b2
je pense mais il le fait ça paraît y
perd logique c'est bien joué tombé 4 il
trouve enfin le contre jeu avec la tour
l'allée de mettre l'euro est fluide
d'ailleurs j'ai pas trop à quoi ça a
servi de faire ça il veut faire un nul
juste il a autant de chocs que ça non
quand même pas un retour c'est 4 ici
autour des 4 l'un ou l'autre je pense
que c'est la même chose je vois pas ce
qu'apporterait de faire jaser ici il
refait tours à huit tours à sète il veut
gagner du temps mais il n'arrive pas à
pousser ses pions cgh donc fouache 5 va
être jouée fou j'ai cas d'accord il
calcule fou prend roi prend tour des 2 h
5 tours b 2 h 6 tours h 2 h 7 mai y
aurait b2 donc qu'il faut faire
autrement
donc fou prend au roi prend tour des 2
t3f 5 tours b de roy prend roi bouge
parce qu'on menace mater tout reprend à
quatre avec l'idée de faire tour b 4 6 3
des 6 et si le roi était parti en 8 on
aurait fait roi au 6 e menaces matt ok
c'est ça l'idée c'est une rentrée droit
un peu comme dans la partie ça être
capable en qatar tac aux verts ils
empêchent donc il faut faire peut-être h
5 h 6 h 7 et sur watch 17 jours à
tourcoing f7 et surtout rachel y aura
fouache trois fois h3 j'imagine ici a
bien joué de la part de ike a hélas il
prend à 4 et une foi qui prend à 4 il
fait très mal en réalité parce que y'a
plus les deux pions passé lié à et va
les prendre b3 maintenant et il a tué le
contre je airwatch 4 et il va pouvoir
faire tout reprend il refait roigé trois
roues à f2 amincie férois j'ai trois
hivers à être en froid même position il
sait quoi il s'est embrouillé avec assez
terrible ça doit qui s'embrouille
et on le voit la caméra il a donné b2
bêtement magna se faire échanger un f5
et ça c'est nul ou pas c'est pas nul du
tout maintenant qu'il a fait h7
ces avantages noir il ya les meilleurs
pion à ses shows les gars y'a le roi qui
va monter et iard wife 5 qui arrivera et
qui a fait n'importe quoi
c'est un tournant du match les gars
c'est un vrai tournant ici et tout
reprend un f4 il n'a pas vu ton prend un
f4 mais ça va suffire quand même ou pas
voilà les deux joueurs qui ont plus de
temps mais normalement il doit pouvoir
rentrer gagner le pion ike qui jouent
tous tempo mais vrai le pion à le pion
qui tombe et c'est perdu
réparti terrible hein qui qui était
vraiment al'avantage dyk et qui
maintenant est complètement gagnée pour
part à mme leroy qui rentre et c'est
terminé et tour ces trois eu deux trois
c4 des trois rois des 3 2 3 des 2 2 en
dame
ça va rentrer tout seul écoeuré like
parce que il la méritait il a mérité
vraiment cette partie mais voilà il
tourne côté par âme et il reste plus
qu'une partie en 5 + 1 et le match qui
est serré comme geagea
ein n'a pas pris en otage cinq le de
jouer le roi après fou 1,8 à mon avis il
aurait pu en prendre h 56 rilov
je pense qu'ils pouvaient je pense qu'il
pouvait mais en fait il a bien mené sa
barque pendant assez longtemps et il a
craqué quand ils ap
il avait son rouage 4 qui était bien il
n'avait plus qu'à prendre en b3 mais il
a dû avoir peur d'un cloud ajout d'un
truc parce que c'était assez effrayant
et du coup après il a re laisser le pion
b2 on a vu que c'était une gaffe et va
dire qu'il y avait plusieurs manières de
gagner mais qui il a il a bien mené sa
barque ont un certain moment jusqu'à ce
qu'il craque donc c'est la dernière
partie de cinq plus un art et une kebano
aérienne qui va être ban de partout
c'est terrible c'est terrible
c'est beau c'est pas comme ça qui va se
faire débat n'est pas ici robin du fou
ils perdent à la 4ème et je pense qu'il
a voulu garder ce conflit cyril off
pendant un long moment parce qu'il a
pris à 4 finalement un moment donné mais
il aurait pu le faire plus tôt m
donc
c'est facile quand on joue par oui parce
que la gaffe en fait nous quand il a
fait tous rêvent de machin enfin on
voyait que ça allait pas mais avec peu
de temps ils ont un peu gaffe et mais
c'est normal le plus sain est vraiment
dur à jouer donc fois ci comme justin
c'est à nouveau une de ces françaises
que j'aime pas trop pour les noirs
simplement là y'a quand même réussi à
bien installer son cavalier à f/5 haïk
et bonsoir lbl 1970 c'est bien tant que
ça a commencé ce fait 1h28
ça va être la dernière partie de la
cadence moi je suivrai le match jusqu'à
19h30 40 et je suivrai pas forcément fin
je serai peut-être les bulles est sur ma
chaîne du coup puisque comme je vous le
disais un peu plus tôt pour ceux qui
arrivent maintenant c'était pas
forcément le match n'était pas prévue
aujourd'hui
et du coup c'était pas évident de
décommander vlad dernière minute parce
que c'est pas juste ça se fait pas
forcément et puis et puis du coup
c'était pour une demi heure c'était un
peu débile en fait c'est pas comme si le
match commence à 19h et qui ont raté la
moitié n'en ratera une portion après
c'est pas de chance si le match est très
très serré mais du coup du coup on verra
la vraie si match est serré on regardera
quand même la fin
mais tours c'est cette fois au tour ce
soit c'est logique mais après il va
faire dame des 5 es ok saddam est quand
même bien placé enfin pour ses 5 c'est
le couple que ce sera un des coûte
candidats très logique
je vais déjà faire torje 6 quand même et
surtour c'est cette dame dessin qui
menacera m'attend g2a mais tourne à mes
torreton g6 qui arrive cet yahoo et de
façon étrange et de donc ouais euh ouais
après s'il ya pas fable a souri speech
et c'est plus une question de de budget
un les gars c'est toujours une question
de budget le problème le truc j'ai déjà
expliqué mille fois mais je erreur
heureux re expliqué pour pour la
millième fois possible avec classe comme
c'est tout une question d'audience tu
vois moi et sur ma chaîne quand je
dépense de l'argent pour les invités
même si ça fait pas plus d'audience en
général je le fais parce que je pense
que c'est qualitatif mais après après
après moi je m'en fous un peu que ça
fasse plus d'audience ou bout moi même
mais après tu fais comme ils sont
vraiment fous l'audience donc
malheureusement le fait d' art de
commentateurs ça augmente pas l'audience
salah réduit même légèrement
en ce pitch est souvent bilic
généralement du coup c'est assez
compliqué de c'est assez compliqué de
leur justifier ça en fait c'est assez
compliqué de leur généré des dépenses
qu'en france en partie donc c'est
différent parce que ta ta ta une plus
value qui est clair en fait
du coup c'est pour ça que pour les
candidats ou les gros tournois je
réussis facilement alors argumenté le
fait d'avoir un deuxième commentateurs
et c'est toujours accepté quasiment tout
cas pour tous les gros thon as a accepté
en revanche pour les blitz
c'est dur bah je sais pas c'est comme si
dans votre dans votre budget ou dans
votre société je sais pas s'il ya des
gens qui ont des sociétés ou qui doivent
organiser des budgets mais c'est comme
ça organiser un événement et je vous
demande de doubler les dépenses pour
quelque chose pour un rapport deux fois
0 enfin faites ça vous coûter deux fois
plus cher mais votre rendement sera le
même voir un petit peu négatif c'est
difficile à à justifier quoi fabricant
je suis fatigué ouais c'est différent
mais bon c'est différent presse passé
comme ça c'est comme ça après fabien
mauvaise internet chez lui aussi ce qui
pose ce qui pose problème ce qui n'est
pas évident sa demande de prêt voire
plus longtemps à l'avancé du coup et
comme il ya plein de changements
d'horaires finalement c'est plus facile
de juger ap un événement de temps en
temps au cac et prend g7 il va prendre
angers 5
mais bon c'est un peu comme moi quand je
vous parlais parfois avec les master
classes ou quad quand je vous dis
parfois c'est pas facile c'est que tu as
moins d'audience et ça me coûte de
l'argent donc tu vois je le fais quand
même parce que parce que je m'emballe
est qu'en vrai mais on soit en soit ça
aucune logique financière de le faire en
fait moi je gère une toute petite
structure donc c'est pas grave mais
quand tu gères un truc qui énorme
forcément c'est comme ça
ouais est donc là
j'ai cinq ans
je sais pas pour les finances c'est pas
ça je passais 45 heures sur twitter par
semaine quand même ou peut-être 40 ou de
tête avec fin je sais pas moi je calcule
avec youtube à chaque fois donc c'est
que pas 60 heures sur ma chaîne par
semaine en gros entre 50 et 60
entre chasse comme emma chaîne donc
quand tu passes 50 60 heures par semaine
sur un truc ça peux pas te rapporter 800
euros net par mois quoi sinon je dis pas
un
j'ai mon matos j'ai mes trucs je suis
obligé de faire du bénef quand même tu
vois mais c'est pas c'est pas 4 master
class par mois qu'ils vont me tuer non
plus mais c'est pas si facile que ça les
gars
mais disons que c'est complètement
différente gérer une chaîne perso ou de
discuter avec un site qui génère qui
génère beaucoup d'argent et après en ce
qui concerne les former en fait le truc
c'est que les gens qui décident des
formats sont pas les mêmes choses que
ceux qui décident de qui commentent en
fait ces deux trucs différents c'est pas
gérée par les mêmes donc en fait ceux
qui font les formats ils font leur
format et après ceux qui se le gars qui
gère un peu avec les audiences les trucs
les budgets lui regarde en fait
lui qu'on parce que ça fait par rapport
aux événements qui la fait les
événements ils sont déjà fait c'est pas
lui qui décide comment il fait les
événements
donc même si je lui fais un retour même
si je lui fais un retour en lui disant
ouais les formats sont pas terribles
c'est pour ça que ça fait pas trop
d'audience fait le guet belges suisses
répondent à un vrai jeu c'est en fait il
va me dire oui en fait il va pas me dire
non il va me dire ou es tu as sûrement
raison
mais en fait mais en fait il se trouve
que c'est pas nous qui décidons donc tu
as le gars il a pas de temps à perdre
ceux des américains tués n'ont pas le
temps à perdre a discuté de trucs comme
ça ils s'en foutent en fait elle même
même si tu as raison ou quoi même si tu
lui dis tu lui dis ça comme argument il
dit oui et alors fait tu fait pas
avancer le truc en fait face et s'est
passé pas le sujet en fait lui c'est pas
sa compétence c'est pas le sujet il a il
bosse il fait lui aussi 50 ou 60 heures
par semaine il n'a pas eu une heure a
pas à perdre pour discuter de ça en fait
donc mais c'est assez logique face et je
comprends là il ya un problème c'est
qu'il n'ya pas d'un problème de pardon
mais il ya peut-être d'alger 5 et dames
ga
bon il ya dame g5 quand même sûrement ou
d'amd 6ème et ya surtout une minute 12
contre contre 6 secondes oued alger ça
ça paraît très fort d'alger ça ne vois
pas de match mais juste ça paraît fort
tu as l'impression qu'il ya un gain mais
j'arrive pas à le trouver
il n'y a pas d'âme g2 ya pas d'argent il
ya tours des tournées katia damas huit
cavaliers h si ça a fait tomber mon cas
je savais que c'était le coup que ils
menacent kg 4 ça faisait peur donc
acquis reprendre deux points on va dire
par rapport au scénario du match
finalement là le score est hyper logique
je dirais vraiment plus deux pour ax et
c'est l'impression que le match a donné
c'est pas spécialement bien payés ni mal
payés parce que je rappelle que par am
cet effet magouille dans dans une game
qu'il avait perdue qui devait gagner et
avec cfm à bout une fois aussi donc on
va dire y ait une magouille chacun mais
du coup les autres partis ont plus ou
moins eu le résultat
logique d'après le cours des parties
dont 5,3 c'est le court c'est le score
logique après un moment dans le match vu
que avec avait vraiment le dessus il
pourrait y avoir plus 4 et le match
pourrait être plié mais l'envahir plus
200% logique avec habiba gap ça manque
d'agilité dans les grosses boîtes suis
tout à fait d'accord mais après c'est le
propre d'une grosse boîte en fait ca il
ya des avantages et des inconvénients
bon alors du coup je vais vous remettre
la partie en entier et on va faire la
petite pause
question est ce que les profs
actuellement ont tous commencé jeune non
tu peux être prof d'échec avoir commencé
plus tard après tu seras pas prof pour
des joueurs trop fort mais tu peux être
initiateur ou prof enfin voilà quoi bon
les mecs je vous mets les je vous mets
la pause on se retrouve dans cinq dix
minutes et je vous remets la partie
depuis le début a tout de suite
alors les gars apparemment je suis
partie un poil plus longtemps que prévu
puisque apparemment un problème
d'internet côté haïk et donc le match
est entre guillemets suspendu mais
suspendu peut-être pour une deux trois
quatre cinq minutes j'étais en train de
lire les messages
ils attendent ils attendent ils
attendent des attentes des nouvelles en
fait il salua maxime qui vient d'arriver
dans le chatt république qui mène 2 0
contre monfils ou est en train de
regarder ça aussi je comprends la pause
mais public est très dangereux public
plutôt juste à petites fautes
d'orthographe sur son nom à la rai qui
en train de revenir ouais ouais on est
en train de sourire déjà c'est bon signe
ça va reprendre
mais mon fils mon fils de 7,0 s'est pas
fait encore un message gars là et pas
ailleurs très enfants et 3 de
préparation il s'est mis à stream et ça
lui réussit moins bien que ça lui
réussit moins bien qu'à cas hikaru
dickhouse et mia stream et il est devenu
beaucoup plus fort et gaëlle celle
inverse
mais il peut il peut largement sortir
après public le problème c'est quand il
en forme il pourrait largement être top
25 mondial à mon avis c'est un c'est un
joueur on va dire un peu comme benoît
paire dans l'esprit c'est que tu peux le
tombé sur sur un public très en forme ou
sur un banc public en sueur et la haye à
deux sets zéro après c'est pas mort 1
trois sets gagnants ça peut se retourner
les montées qui à 12 partout dans le
cinquième
la mauvaise nouvelle pour muter c'est
que avoir enchaîné il joue l'équivalent
de hockey il ya eu premier set 6 0 pour
lyon va pas le comté mais il ya eu 7 6 7
6 dans les deux autres c'est vrai qu'il
va avoir joué à 5h22 bahia peut-être
s'en sortir mais ça ira pas au bout du
grand chelem quoi ça c'est sûr commencer
par un match aussi long
c'est pas vraiment ce qu'on souhaite
non maintenant c'est par amitié un
problème de connexion ou là ça va être
compliqué ce match ça va être compliqué
alors du coup il revient ça avait bien
marché jusque là ça fait marrer haïk jeu
comme assez content que ce roland garros
se joue même si il ya des problèmes de
météo et tout ça ça va ils réussissent à
jouer mais je trouve moi je trouve que
c'est plutôt bien il faut en c'est en
cette période on obligé d'être confiné
fait un confiné en objet de faire
attention où vous faut pas trop sortir
de chez soi pas aller dans des endroits
trop trop peuple et surtout la
maintenance
c'est l'hiver on peut plus être trop en
extérieur je trouve que c'est bien
qu'ils aient un livre qui est des
divertissements comme ça que le sport
reprenne à la télé ça donne quand même
un peu quelque chose à faire chez soi je
vous c'est plutôt une bonne chose qu'ils
jouent même si même s'ils voient ya pas
de public même s'il ya des problèmes de
météo bassa'a presse et c'est un peu
imprévisible les problèmes de météo tu
peux tomber sur deux super semaine en
octobre comme deux semaines de pluie
après c'est un peu le un peu un peu une
question de chance mais en soi
perso que c'est plutôt bien que ça
reprenne gens sont bloqués chez eux au
moins ils ont quelque chose à regarder
et vous manger quelque chose à regarder
si pas trop le temps malheureusement
mais au moins ça fait ça fait un peu de
distraction je trouve c'est plutôt cool
perçoit
quand même un esprit bizarre en france
dix ans tout le monde crie parce que
quand il pleut les matchs s'arrête il
bâche les cours et maintenant le
problème c'est que la pluie fait du
bruit non en fait en france les gens
sont jamais contents d'y lien c'est
systématique c'est systématique
que ce soit à raison ou à tort en fait
ça sont point positif que du coup on a
un esprit critique quand même ça c'est
bien mais à mais le truc c'est que c'est
qu'on va être un peu systématiquement à
dans la critique de tous alors que là
pour la peine le fait qu'ils le jouent
c'est plutôt c'est plutôt un passé
plutôt bien il ya des défauts évidemment
ça peut pas être parfait de toute façon
le monde dans lequel ils vivent souvent
n'est pas parfait mais mais d'essayer de
faire quelque chose avec la avec une
bonne volonté je trouve que c'est plutôt
bien
après je suis sûr que la moitié des gens
qui sont pas d'accord avec moi mais bon
c'est comme ça qu'on apprend dans des 4
donc là ces deux nouveaux ike qui
allaient blanc ce début de set où il
vient de gagner avec les noirs et ils
sont repartis dans l'arago zink il a un
peu modifié
avec les blancs mais ça j'aime bien avec
les vins j'ai l'impression qu'on va
réussir attaqué le roi ce pion aux 5000
m'excite à chaque fois elle est là ça
m'excite ya il ya quatre pièces qui sont
qui peuvent être braqués vite sur le roi
et même des cavaliers six échecs qui
peuvent se regarder des à trois
cavaliers des six détour d un
j'adore la position des blancs ici
séparé ce que tu dis tu me fait changer
d'avis sur la tenue de roland de ce
roland garros j'aime bien changer d'avis
merci tonton foot après c'est mon avis
hein
mais je vois là vu les conditions dans
lesquelles on est après tu peux voir le
truc d'un autre côté tu as une autre
manière de voir les choses c'est de te
dire c'est un roland garros aura b celui
qui va le gagner et pas et pas forcément
le plus légitime c'est c'est vrai en
fait c'est complètement vrai mais d'un
autre côté ce que dans la période dans
laquelle on vit le fait que celui qui
gagne roland garros soit le plus
légitime soit dans des conditions
normales ou est ce que on essaye de
bricoler ce qu'on peut et de de faire au
mieux et de se dire bon ben voilà pas
période exceptionnelle mesure
exceptionnelle et et on verra quand le
monde pourra reprendre une vie
complètement normale
attendez asie qui écrit un truc marrant
un de mes mentors dans la dev comparer
les développeurs faire les
développements aux usa en chine et en
france aux usa ils font un truc très
vite il se vend très bien mais il ya des
bugs alors on tue le développeur qui a
fait le truc et on recommence enfin
querrey c'est vrai en plus j'imagine ça
se passe un peu comme ça mais pour
bosser pour une boîte américaine en plus
en chine on passe cinq ans a développé
un truc hyper robuste qu'on ne touchera
plus jamais après ouais ça ressemble un
peu à ça en france on va s'engueuler
pendant un an sur la dissolution du
bureau deux ans sur ce que doit être
produit on va passer six mois à
développer un truc hyper propres ouais
c'est vrai que c'est caricatural
évidemment mais c'est vrai que c'est un
peu comme ça oui
en france on va perdre beaucoup de temps
à faire n'importe quoi on va être très
efficace après ce point qu'il prend au
sein qui met la pression sur le cavalier
armé n'a pas d'âme b4 arrive aux
cavaliers f3 gf3 tour des six d'anne
decis d'anne decis fois c'est trois sets
au tour des six d'accord ils acceptent
de rentrer dans la finale avec qualité
de moins qui doit être nul
ouais c'est trois sets et reprend des
six il va faire f 4 3g 2 mai ouais f4 ce
serait l'idée d'un peu bloqué tous les
poussées et roy g2c d'être plus robuste
peut-être 3g 3 et f4 maintenant ça doit
être nul ce truc là ces trucs là sont
généralement nul quand est-ce qu'ils
passent aux trois plus un ils sont aux
trois plus un maintenant ça doit être
mieux mais c'est quand même les blancs
qui prennent tous les cas les noirs vont
jamais gagné ça en tu peux la gagner si
les blancs force au pire les blancs
pourrait faire tourner france et si on
prend ces six tours france et 6 nuls
immédiatement qu'elle a il ya peut-être
g4 tourage 3 qui est dangereux montour
c5 ça mange pas de pain et il faut
peut-être joué en f3 rapidement war h3
réage 3 convient c'était pour éviter g4
6 b 4
à 6
à troyes d'accord
et ce qui veut sacrifier au bon moment
en fait peut-être ça qui prépare le tour
h4 tour eiffe tour f3 maintenant c'est
ça le truc ce qu'avec les blancs à force
de vouloir trop la gagne ça peut devenir
dangereux mais maintenant il va
prononcer si je pense prise prise il y
aura à 5 puis on prend 1,5 et tour à
quatre et c'est nul mais dans cette fin
avec la qualité de plus les blancs
étaient jamais vraiment beaucoup mieux
exactement ce que je vous disais hé bé à
tour prend 1,4 mde le tour à quatre
c'est même les noirs qui sont
sensiblement mieux donc il fait à 5
baies 5 ans et à surtour à quatre des
six attention à surtour à 4 tours c3
pourtour b3 b6 c'était bien joué b5 avec
id tour ces trois
bien qu'ils aient maintenant tour des
six et il a pas tomber trois ça c'est
nul
et ça c'est nul donc haye qui a dû être
précis après pour aller trouvez-les
annule finalement c'est par am qui a dû
être précis dans un premier temps et
avec dans un deuxième jaune qui va être
la tour en deux sets où tout reste cet
endroit est froid et enfin bref un bref
quatre sur wave 4 il veut quoi
roy eux deux est d'accord sur tourbe et
de roy a eu un bref trois tours échec
peut-être wife un même même airways 3
tours ces trois rois g2 peut-être tours
et sète c'est bien joué ces barèmes qui
presse plus tôt il repart anciens ils
mèneront ces deux là et c'est bien joué
la tour qui va repartir par alaba tour
j'ai cinq tours à 5 doit faire un nul
déjà il fait tour f5 f3 et torah 5
maintenant alors c'était pour empêcher
tourbe et trois tours prend h3 et leur
dit que c'est gagnant pour les noirs
maintenant ouais ses gains pour les
noirs parce que puis on prend il ya tour
tour ftf de f1 oh c'est terrible il va
mettre deux échecs tour f5 maintenant où
tout reprend m et on prend 1,4 on crève
de sang est là c'est terrible tourbe et
k3 cette iapp à tour b 1
c'est perdu ouais et f1 dame au like qui
a vraiment fait n'importe quoi là dans
cette finale
il y avait vraiment de dix mille
manières de faire nul et il en a pas
trouvé une seule
difficile nationalité c'est iran pour
parra mais enfin iranien pour parham et
en arménien pour pour ike
mais ouais non il s'est fait arnaquer
quand même salma elle se retrouve à être
pas facile à jouer avec les blancs cette
finale il aurait dû prendre ses six plus
tôt en réalité et y aller pour faire nul
il a essayé de la poussée un peu de pain
pas trop longtemps mais l'essai d'un peu
la poussée et après c'est devenu chose
devenir un peu mieux pour parra mais il
n'a pas réussi à se réajuster
je vous avais dit que ces finales
qu'elle était mieux pour les blancs mais
parfois ça pouvait fin et que tu pouvais
faire nul tout de suite mais que ça
pouvait parfois tourner et ça a été le
cas
intéressant intéressant là on à l'ouest
indienne qui s'est développée enfin je
crois en tout cas je nettement pas tout
à fait vu l'ouverture et on va avoir ce
problème de pioncer 7 il va y avoir une
prise et une tour en c1
donc ça a évolué de manière intéressante
pour les blancs il y aura une tour en c1
et ça va jouer là dessus
j'avais eu 5 qui s'en prend à la casse
six escales des joueurs d'échecs qui
pour raisons géopolitiques entre pays ne
peuvent pas s'affronter où il ya un
problème avec les joueurs iraniens qui
n'ont pas le droit d'affronter des
joueurs israéliens qui va échanger
tablette qui m'écrit un truc pour un
master class ce soir
kiev 5 4 5 français n'est pas bon début
j'ai pas compris le pion était en l'air
alors alors ici tu peux pas le faire ce
que sur cavaliers à 5 adam prend b4 et
ici tu peux pas le faire parce qu'ils
avouent prend à 5 et plus tôt et plus
tôt tu peux pas le faire ce que le pion
il n'est pas en l'air donc ya pas un
savon tu as fait à temps je joue le
temps il regarde juste
pandev laddh il y avait qui m'écrit
qu'il est déjà là mais en fait c'est
20h30
du coup les 19 heures donc je suis pas
trop ce qui m'écrit je suis pas sûr
qu'il ait compris qu'on est un conte
avait un créneau horaire différent
il me fait suer une telle issue l'est
jusqu'en même
non mais tu est en fait il écrit à la
mauvaise personne ou quoi
je passe sur art compris il ya un truc
de jeu passeur a compris on va voir et
cette position c'est de commencer mieux
pour les noirs il n'a pas réussi à fixer
ses sets et c'est bizarre mais le fou
blanc est complètement au muret et c'est
quand même plutôt les noirs qui ont du
jeu les pions eux ils sont ils sont
bloqués en fait c'est plutôt les noirs
qui vont réussir à créer un pion pas
assez bon quoique spa sur soi mieux pour
les noirs mais en tout cas c'est plus ou
moins bien c'est issa christine calloc'h
pour mettre cet échec
parti un peu bizarre mais je checke du
coup ça m'a déconcentré
j'ai pas ce qu'il faut en fait je
m'attends au pire grave que ces 20h30
moscou c'est possible c'est possible
tête il s'est trompé de personne qu'il
écrive un message peut-être que je sais
pas il ya plein de possibilités
différentes
bon en tout cas dans la partie a juste
une qualité de moins du coup 5 et voilà
cette suite finie via le pur h 4 qui va
tomber un nid à tour ses six encore
c'est pas tout de suite finie pardon
j'avais pas vu ce contre eux je vais
peut-être dames 7 protège le pion aux 5
c'est pas fini fini ça va être gagnant
pour les noirs mais c'est pas fini fini
non je pense c'est une incompréhension
et trucks qui me répond pas
je passais pas ils me répondent pas
cessé d'appeler la mauvaise personne ou
quoi madame g6 là c'est fort puisqu'il
va gagner le pion hk tu vas être le
ronde et si c'est le pion b est passé ça
refait plus deux pour haïk
il est 20h sept actuellement en russie
alors la russie est plus grande que ce
que tu penses ce maître yogourt
la russie a un petit peu plus de fuseau
horaire que alors que la france
métropolitaine c'est sûr mais je pense
que même en comptant mais quoique en
comptant les outre mer on a quand même
beaucoup de d'outre-mer oui il à moscou
mais il aurait très bien pu ne pas être
à moscou la russie est vaste la russie
va de kaliningrad à vladivostok
c'est vaste non c'est bien sûr aussi
bien pour sa banque et feuilles que j'ai
précisé la france métropolitaine
mais oui la france voir beaucoup de
fuseaux horaires
ben avec la guyane toutes les îles en
polynésie on a beaucoup de fuseaux
horaires différents
la guyane c'est énorme a d'ailleurs
barça c'est toujours cette ragots sinon
il se retrouve avec ce pion aux cinq
qu'on aime bien c'est pas super en
langage c vraiment grand la guyane c'est
que sur un seul fuseau je pensais que
c'était plus qu'un fuseau je pensais
qu'ils allaient deux fusées en guyane
donc d4 donc il prend l'espace un plomb
tout bête ça peut être fois de fougue et
un cavalier des six dames e41 avec h 4 h
c'est un peu long mais si tu le mets en
place efficace hein
un peu long il peut aussi le faire par
passant par food et 3 mais je pense
c'est plus logique de mettre le flanc à
deux il fait foi de ces le coup que
j'aurais vous aussi il va se faire
échanger une fois il a peut-être qu'à
aider 6 mai accueil prend 1,5 et t'as
pas le temps de magouilles assez parce
qu'il va prendre en f3 sur échec
il fait h4 mais sans les tourangeaux ça
va être moins - moins violent
donc
si t'as pas le temps de donner attaque
par contre avec la paire de fouet le
pion aux cinq qui est faible ça risque
de très bien tourné pour pour part avec
les noirs ici ça va être lui qui va être
mieux d'ailleurs il gagne un pion
enfin le truc ce qui prend des 6 es fou
17 alors là ses pions de moins
le pion des six il est complètement
entouré il peut plus avancer et il n'y a
pas d' attaque sur le roi donc ça c'est
high que c'est la deuxième fois qu'ils
ratent complètement cette structure de
pions
voilà gundy c'est un sixième de la
france métropolitaine en superficie je
trouve moi je trouve que c'est grand
quand il pense tu vas tu pourrais penser
que c'est un petit territoire quelque
part au loin mais en vrai c'est un
territoire gigantesque enfin moi ça me
paraît être un territoire gigantesque
c'est pas genre une petite île où un
petit truc en fait c'est énorme et ça
une frontière terrestre assez dense à
une frontière
ce qu'elle est et reste la frontière
choix qui est un pont qui mène de la
guyane au brésil
mais ce qu'il ya une longue frontière
terrestre ou pas
après 23 ans intéresse avec le brésil et
je crois qu'il ya un énorme pompe qui
étaient construits a pas si longtemps
mais du coup c'est fou en fait quand il
pense qu'on a une énorme frontière
terrestre avec le brésil samse c'est pas
un truc pas géopolitiquement parlant ou
quoi c'est pas c'est pas un truc auquel
tu penserais de base mais la france
c'est quand même un truc de ouf ça ça
plombe frontières tu as de la france
un petit 730 km mais c'est fou quand tu
y penses tu argenté pas là ici chez toi
à dire on a une énorme frontières
terrestres a et il ya peut-être un
problème de la pensée perdons depuis
longtemps avec le brésil il n'a pas fait
d'un problème de ces bizarres
c'était sur échec ouais économiquement
et si c'est important et c'est vrai que
c'est les choses auxquelles on pense pas
tu vois à free qui fera que ce qui
aiguille année du poussin par la guyane
situe si tu habites en guyane
il peut prendre des dames g1 qui a
validé quatre roues qui a aidé quatre
direct bon il va à la perdrix il est
très mal il a le pion de moins
le cavalier qui va revenir vers f5 qui
va peut-être se prendra six échecs
intermédiaire on va prendre six qui
apprend f7 aidé à me prendre c'est
bizarre de parfaits h6 là c'est leur dit
qu'ils me le donnait comme redonnant
l'avantagé aux blancs mais c'est hyper
logique qui leur apprend cavaliers avec
cette dame g6 et si le roi recul tu
pousses champions je trouve qu'ils font
beaucoup de fautes lanz ait notes qui
sont pas des fautes qu'on a l'habitude
de voir
voilà c'est le bordel total la partie a
plus rien d'humain
le roi qui appartient h 4 f3 sa menace
dame f2 à temps et sur la suite dame
damage deux rois ici non il ya cavale et
h3 holbach loup au et là il ya là avec
le tarifit maths et damas fuite
bon il rate les maths en 1 mais ils
échangent les dames mais il a raté les
maths en un vrai je voulais dire là les
deux joueurs sont plus très en forme
raté deux fois m'attendent 1 c'est chaud
mais c'est vrai que qui en sort
vainqueur et qui reprend trois points à
la salle à elle fait mal parce qu'il
était vraiment perdant tout le long
du coup ouais ça fait plus 3 et là je
dirais le score qui enfle du mauvais
côté on vole attirant répond plus
nîmes inquiète fois la surface de ce
soir humain qui a team inquiète donc la
petite anglaise joué par par am
peur
ce jeu kaka jeu spécial du nord c'est 20
20 20 ans enfin je crois que ses 20 ans
au 1er janvier 2020 pas dire il faut
avoir 19 ans au 1er janvier 2020 je
crois ouais c'est ça et tu peux avoir 20
ans fait du coup à le 2 janvier un coup
c'est moins de 21 ans quoi tu pourrais
avoir 20 ans et 375 quatre jours le 31
décembre quoi
l'apprenti on prend un 4 4 c'est le plan
classique
donc je lui prends un f6 f ça il va
faire f 4k je pense quand même je pense
f4 ou trois f4 essayer de jouer sur ce
fou là et sur se fout là
damages 5
ça doit être mieux pour les blancs après
serait une très mauvaise nouvelle pour
parham de perdre cela il peut il peut
pas se permettre de la perdre sa la pa
ram
parce que là après à moins comme je vous
ai dit en fait moins 3 pour moi c'est le
secteur - 3 - 4 c'est le secteur où tu
peux remonter -5 c'est fini donc là il
est vraiment sous pression après les une
bonne position avec les blancs saddam en
h5 est indélogeable et le tapis si le
fou qui t'a bien f4 qui est la rupture
il allait rupture il peut se placer au
centre avaient préparé des trucs
je vais allumer la lumière ça paraît
mieux pour les blancs disent avoir un
fait 6 un truc c'est que la structure
est meilleur dans me2 il revient il
anticipe les fouets f7 mais du coup le
pion avec six blocs le fou donc quand on
va jouer des quatre la différence c'est
qu'après pu en prendre qu on prend le
petit on arrive si c'est bien moins bien
que quand f7 sache passer des trucs que
vous sentez
on espère que ce match pour autant que
mouté gustino assure toutefois que le
commandent pas jusqu'à la fin mba chess
bombay ce soir il ya le court quand même
important enfin je pense un la du couple
a dit me fait flipper j'ai peur qu'ils
nous refassent je suis je suis semi
inquiet que qu'on se retrouve avec le
même problème qu on avait eu un lundi je
fais un peu inquiète je suis un peu
inquiet donc là on voit les problèmes
maria le fou qui arrive en h5 le pion
scc purifie si je pense c'était vraiment
horrible
un encan vlad arrête de répondre qu'il
écrit des messages bizarres ça
m'inquiète un peu après ça veut rien ça
veut rien dire aussi ça le problème avec
vlad c'est qu'en fait il peut juste être
en train d'analyser un truc aux échecs
et du coup tu peux pas lui parler c'est
tu peux pas trop savoir en fait
pourquoi pas vrai la colonne gmail a le
temps en vrai avec les blancs les noirs
ont aucun plan parce que genre si tu
fais e 4 il peut avoir kg 2 kf4 aussi
même au delà d'autres problèmes
je pense qu'il est bourré
potentiellement ou pas ils ont que
j'irais plutôt non mais la probabilité
passé de 0 % à 35 on va dire enfin pas
de zéro mais de 5 à 35 on va dire ça
comme ça
va dire ça comme ça devient fou
arrivants h5 qui fait le cas donc on va
le fou g7 qui est complètement enterré
les blancs qui sont beaucoup mieux
par exemple quand on est passé de 5% à
35 en l'espace de 20 minutes quoi donc
il a filé le pion et dernier cet accord
il veut jouer le pion de moins et il
veut s'activer par tour des huit
attaques et ça a il va faire h5 et
fourrages 6 et il ya f sans arrêt mais
il a complètement retourné le truc en
vrai enfin c'est fou c'est fou c'était
complètement mauvais est ce qu'il avait
comme position et là ça devient très
chaud par am je sais pas à quel moment
s'est mal passé fois-ci ciapa tour des 3
on a eu quatre
donc ça peut être une option il fait 4
direct
le cavalier qui repart flash 6
maintenant il va prendre des katja pas
tourcoing 4 à cause de cavaliers trois
tours prend des 1
il va échanger il va faire quoi que
trois pions prend tour des trois c'est
logique ou tomber catway même idée de
prendre en b 3e prise prises et là aucun
échec et tours b 2 alors est-ce qu'il ya
toujours sept nuls ça j'en sais rien il
a pris du foot c'était bien joué et
maintenant b5 comprend et il veut faire
à 4 ha ouais c'est très bien joué là ce
que ferrique donc il va prendre des six
cavaliers f3 à 3 qui est pro d2 à 2
j'imagine à tour aux 6 à 2 il doit pas y
avoir de trucs avec le cavalier la tour
auquel il veut faire cavalier ou cinq
rois et fuite cavaliers 17 3 g 7 tours
c'est 3 6 bon il fait froid ici tour où
il évoquait la tour 7 c'est ridicule
hier est fou g5 comprend tour brillant
c'était ridicule tour cette tour cet été
ridicule et ça fait quatre points
d'écart est donc la haye qui avait
légèrement dominés 1 le 3 + 1
une mise en route dans le cinq plus un
pardon et une mise en route difficile
dans le trois plus un mail à 8,4 il
rentre vraiment dans le dans le secteur
où et c'est pas fini à 100% mais on va
dire qu'il a un bon 95% de chances de
gagner le match à présent
donc ouais c'est c'est cesser c'est dur
pour pam qui est moins fort bien voilà
on voit on voit qu'il est moins fort
donc
la tour en d1 le fond et de fougue et
cette petit rock aux 5
phocéen il repart avec le fou le fou
souvent on peut le revoir un revenir sur
sa case de départ
que ce soit le fou noir ou tout blanc
après avoir rentré les tours ils sont
assez bien placé sur la case de départ
suivant les positions 1 mais souvent
c'est un placement intéressant ce des
pièces longue portée qui peuvent
ressortir après d'un côté ou de l'autre
mais qui gênent pas les autres pièces
pendant le jeu des quatre est là il va
prendre le pion isolé qui va arriver
rami a peut-être des carriers b4 qui
vont rodez qui vont être très pénible
donc ils commencent par à 3 parce que
l'on est cloué
et salua peter dans le chatt uipa sua
dit bonjour j'ai pu rater son message
aurait donc pions isolé pollution
complexe une nouvelle fois que vous
décidez de jouer mais ils font des trois
cavaliers cette tête tu vas faire car
hélios est ce pour vous qu'est des 50 à
faire car il ya eu 4 ou cavaliers au
sein algérien qui a valu à cinq quand le
cavalier s'en va pour venir en dessin
que j'aime bien mettre en jeu 5 ouais ça
c'est cool à imposition est compliqué
ils ou c5 hypercomplexes fillon prend
fou prend fourrage sept cavaliers achète
ça donne une deux trois pièces contre la
dame c'est trop donc on peut pas le
faire pour ceux qui se posaient la
question ça donne 3 points 6 points 11
points contre 9 en vrai trois pièces
toujours plus fort car il peut jouer un
coup de cavaliers avec l'idée de faire
des c fou prend et fo h7 qui a valu au
cas donc c'est l'idée que je veux quand
je vous parlais tout à l'heure pour un
peu échangé peut-être tout liquider
faire un nul en vrai hockey prend des
cats et peut-être joie pour éviter le
purise mais bon pourquoi vouloir éviter
le pion isolé sais pas si mauvais un pur
isolé s'ils vont commencer à ce groupe i
ça peut même être une force
donc là il va les changer du coup
position va être assez égale y aura un
matériel équivalent pas spécialement
plus d'activités pour un jour le dossier
ouais les normes peut-être mais embraye
sur tour des huit adam g4 menace
fourrage saison qui a même pas plus
d'activités pour les noirs c'est
vraiment aidé à l'égal fou et 3 es fou
des quatre demandes dans le chat les
américains ont gagné il ya un an ils ont
perdu donc à ça va faire des échanges
massif ça va faire un nul je vais aller
tchèque le temps qui reste
quoique c'est pas fait encore un an ce
match il ya eu des surprises
ça peut il peut encore des surprises
dans cette partie même si savoir le
chrono officiel
il reste 23 minutes ouais faut vraiment
qu'il faudra qu'il revienne au moins 1 -
2 - 3 quoi avant l'avant de bullet on va
dire - 4 - 4 c'est trop vraiment par là
c'est juste égal
après il peut y avoir des gaffes mais
c'est symétrique symétrique pad pas de
problème pour un joueur ou pour l'autre
suspect changer les fous et à permettre
le carré les ans des cats il venait de
faire rager deux faits retour eux un roi
g2c le plus logique d'activer le roi va
chez en surface sans réponses évasives
de vlad ouais ça ça me fait suer on
saura mais attends est-ce que c'est pas
les blancs qui se met à être mieux
maintenant parce que tu as quand même à
6 en l'air et tous rêvent d un assez
sérieux qui domine il a réussi à gagner
la paire de fou enfin la paire de foule
le fou par nom face aux cavaliers qui
est super bien placé
j'ai l'impression que la cdu craquage
mentale de la part de pam va faire f 4
wild 3 f 5 g 4 tours des huit c'est bien
aussi
il va prendre prendre m à tour des 6 à 7
à 5 tours b si c'est maintenant f4
sûrement et expansion pour ces six pas
bêtes ils empêchent cavaliers c5 par
amenant mal autant j'aime bien le f4 qui
part maintenant le roi f3 le g4 f5
s'arrête
peut-être nul mais c'est dur à défendre
faux seins kpaka vallée des saints qui à
tour dé 6,6 menace tour bessette et les
finales de droit vont sûrement être
gagnante la + 5 par contre c'est le truc
que tu peux pas avoir des 6 3 c'est 3,4
j'imagine ça rentre et maintenant à
quatre pour garder les pions il prend le
pion je pensais qu'ils feraient fuir à
quatre pour faire tourbe et 6 mai il
fait ça pour faire tour des caf ou c3 où
il bien joué et bien joué pardon pays
tient il tient la baraque et il a assis
sous pression roi des cas trois c4 rwc
ab3 roi aque à 3,5 j'imagine ce qui veut
essayer de faire son soutien tous les
pions et s'attaquer tout reprend des 5 3
4 ça doit gagner ce que tu arrive quand
même très vite sur à 5 et sur cavaliers
c'est cette fosse 5
elle reprend à 6 d'accord il veut le
blocus sur v5 pas mais faut cinq rois
ici a et b 3 à laon b 3 c'est par zoug
langues
alors la france ce serait cette position
et melilla cavaliers à trois arrivées
trois c'est mal joué il fallait réussir
à faire un bras à retrouver la même
position
maintenant ça doit plus gagné mais
c'était hyper dur à faire avec peu de
temps sur la pendule là le roi va
bouffer b4 et b3 et le cavalier va
prendre f6 il a raté quelque chose ici
eric fallait réussir à tournicoter la
même et revenir dans cette position là
avec le très haut noir veste est gagnant
mais en faisant b3 en fait ils donnent
la case à trois ils enlèvent les autres
langues
non là c'est donc maintenant française
d' avance donc ça a changé deux
françaises mais ouais
ike qui a raté qui a raté un nouveau
break mais bon il est il est quand même
bien devant son adversaire maintenant
dans toutes les parties il est
systématiquement plus fort et il est
vraiment rentré dans le dans leur haine
je gagne entre guillemets
il est rentré dans le règne gagnant en
terme de points
voilà ça waroquet way
alors est-ce qu'il va tenter cavaliers à
3 pour passer un bep 5,5 et à 3 pour
menacer kébé 5 et sur a6 qui essaient 2
qui a aidé quatre ce qui est un plan
très classique pour venir vie c'est la
case des 4 il faut prendre avec de
s'adonner quoi a ici je crois que ça va
être théorique roi f1 fou 17 et s ok ça
doit juste être une variante se doit
juste exister en fait mais je sais pas
théoriquement ce que ca donne il salua
ucigos mu haine parfois le tchèque est
là à la théorie un cil a pas joué c'est
qu'il y aura des problèmes soient pas
être super jusqu il décide de pas joué
cette variante on dirait que vous serez
enfermerait
dimpre en c3 et peut-être 3,17 ici avec
l'idée de menacer dame prend f3 parce
qu'ici sur d'emprunt f3 ya dame prend g8
intermédiaire sur échec en plus méric et
peut-être pas très bien ici avec les
noirs
dans lequel il va arriver en d4 et le
roi noir est tellement faible
en plus il ya un pion de plus pour les
blancs n'ont cessé 1
c'est un fiasco cette française la de
ike
dames 1 3 voilà c'est vraiment cathala
position là ses katas il faut juste
trouver un moyen de justin koua moore a
atteint parfois tranquille parfois
justin roy h1 et peio histoire 2 puis
avoir de problème sur f3 quoique non
même ces dames pro f 3 ar sur dame
pranger 8,1 la dame et ce calme en c3 où
ses cinq as et cinq c'est plus logique
comment elle se fait plus attaquer et b6
est ok sur tourbe et 5 qui va repartir
dans ces huit peut-être il part en a
trois ok pour menacer dame prend 1,4
juste à titre informatif l'ordi donne
depuis tout à l'heure cavaliers prend
aussi ses cahiers des quatre comme
gagnant pour les blancs parce qu'en fait
s'il va revenir en russie c'est va
gagner la tour mais les deux joueurs le
voit pas ça fait peut-être cinq six
coups que l'ordi donne ça comme gagnant
cette dame 17 maintenant et par am qui
aura pas trouvé le gain alors il peut
avoir décidé de bouger le cavalier de
mètres la tour en f3 j'imagine que tu
vas faire pousser cinq ans mais
maintenant sur da match ici larroy
hausse est mon roi 8 mai on a
l'impression que c'est activé avec les
noirs bon après il ya quand même le pion
h qui va vraiment c'est quand même très
bien pour pour les blancs mais ce avec
une fois que tu as vu le coût de
l'ordinateur car il ya eu 6 c'était
tellement fine tout de suite en fait
alors il va sûrement faire damer phcie
saeki dh set ça fait tellement mal
ok dams est il n'empêche que ce avec
damas 6h 7h 8 c c'était terrible et là
sur https la tourache 8 pour le moment
mais cavaliers gesa kg 5 qui veut contre
attaquer sur des 4es prendre g5 à la fin
pour le moment il défend haïk
voilà je vous annonce que si parham la
percée c'est jamais fini fini mais ça va
lui faire très très mal à la carafe et
en cas de nul
ce serait quand même très compromettants
pour lui faut vraiment qu'ils la gagnent
salle a par am
là il se retrouve mal autant et il
réussit pas là terminée et il réussit
pas la terminer il
carélie g5 j'imagine et cavaliers ces
systèmes pos et il se fait contre
attaquer sur des quatre noms il lui
reste neuf secondes il a pas réussi à
finir ike et bien il va perdre une
calloc'h sont des quatre alors l'ordi
redonne encore cavaliers ci serait parce
que du coup ils gagnent g7 sur échec
raté par ike nouvelle faute tactique
dans ce match alors là il n'a pas pu
calculer toutes les variantes un parent
à mahé mais croyez fuite et à cavalier
ou six quelle faute de haïti si énorme
énorme erreur du joueur arméniens qui
craquent une nouvelle fois et qui laisse
et qui laisse par âme dans le match adam
g7 était une faute et 3e sets aussi
derrière mais des partis qui sont très
compliquées donc on comprend que les
joueurs réalisent de telles fautes
tactiques c'est pas délirant la sueur
fou prend un f2 roigé de les pièces
seront trop instable qui va rentrer dans
cette finale qui est perdante mais qui
va essayer de défendre pendant quelques
coups la tour qui vient bessette angers
5-6 il va essayer de se construire à 1
un genre de château on va dire mais par
am qui va essayer de doubler à un moment
donné est rentré dans une finale de
pions gagnante pour faire garde de
passant d'une fourchette en réalité
c'est le seul danger mais elle est
passive règne du roi 3 kg 4 déjà hélas
il ya carélie h5 qui est pour un f4 elle
et on prend un f4 du coup il s'est fait
prendre le lion paix ça c'est nul
maintenant parce que tour cavaliers
contre tours c'est nul alors ça peut
être chiant à faire avec
avec toutes les tours sur l'échiquier
avec peu de temps avec eux qui me je
sais pas trop ce qui fait avec cavaliers
aussi c'est bien joué et ça c'est assez
simple à annuler j'ai déjà réussi avec
peu de temps sur la pendule
et ça va nous faire tourner la pendule
du match en plus pendant un assez long
moment
ce qui est plutôt en faveur s'il y
arrive de ike et quel point f8
elle a en plus il se prend la fourchette
avec qui en profitent pour un petit peu
récupéré il fait quoi
il a attendu et récupère un peu
mentalement et il prend la nulle rsa là
elle fait très très mal parce qu'il
était gagnant à deux moments différents
dans la partie le joueur le joueur a le
joueur iranien pardon est il là il la
gagne pas quand même
autant dire que ça fait mal ça fait même
très mal et c'est un retour de parra mme
d'un retour de wayne un retour de parra
manquait
ouais il ya eu pas mal de ratés côté
côté parham dans la partie précédente
c'est vrai que lecavalier prend aussi ce
qui a aidé car s'il n'était pas
impossible à avoir un c'est vrai qu'il
n'était pas facile il était pas facile à
voir mais bon il a raté tellement de
fois il aurait pu y penser
il a quand même fait beaucoup d'erreurs
je trouve par âme et même dans la finale
où ils avaient deux tours avec quelques
cavaliers pourquoi il est pas l'écrouer
le cavalier c'est de rentrer dans la
finale gagnante a été parce c'était pas
facile à faire un mais je crois qu'ils
sont embêtés a poussé son pion alors
qu'il aurait pu il aurait pu faire
différemment presse un match très
tactique compliqué et je veux surtout
pas alors jeté la pierre ça joue assez
bien je trouve
mais mais par am qui rate de trois
petites occasions par ci par là pour
rivaliser avec avec cai qu'il faudrait
il faudrait qu'il fasse le match parfait
mike est légèrement plus fort il le fait
pas donc là on a un roc opposé mais on
voit une tour qui peut arriver en lien
avec un fou en c3 ça peut faire très mal
elle a fait 5 du coût chasse le fou il
va peut-être prendre en dessin qui ré où
ils chassent et le cavalier mettre le
fou en c3 mais ça paraît ça paraît très
dangereux c'est même très dangereux
il va faire cinq à six noms là là là ça
ça va sûrement on va sûrement arriver
dans la zone du +5 j'ai regardé combien
il reste deux temps dans la cadence
je ré ouvre un petit coup d'arrêt cette
news a récupéré cette partie et celle et
celle d'après elle a du coup à tour g1
tour j'ai cinq ans fin août ou rage et
un ton g5 dont j'ai un et f6
il commence par f 6
ça fait très mal le fou qui va arriver à
f5
c'est pas étonnant c'est pas étonnant ce
résultat et qui est vraiment comme
visait un gros joueur détaille-t-elle
tuesday qui est vraiment bon et c'est
pas étonnant de le voir remporter ce
match c'est les quarts de finale aurait
deux gares
solution savait plus écrasante il ya
quelques coupes tatave si c'était
prématuré laissé cette fois arrivé à
angers 4 c'était peut-être pas
obligatoire thorens parce qu'il donne à
mon avis il veut éviter les tours prend
1,5 et les problèmes sur ce fou ou trois
fautes 3 était pas bien inspiré c'était
pas bien inspirés face f 5,6 à un bon
moment autour des 1 c'est bien jouer il
va voir dame prendre trois là le niveau
de jeu a largement baissé de la part des
deux hommes
on voit des partis assez décousu vous
c'est plus forcément le joueur qui
domine de base qui gagne d'aller voir un
petit peu de fatigue ils ont joué des
parties très tactique et sur tours d2 le
problème cgf et fourrages 6 alors là
c'est terrible ça c'est terrible ardiden
complètement guillaume pour les noirs
n'y a rien à faire contre cette menace
et par am qui va revenir dans le match
by qui semblait au dessus
ouais mais là qui est une réelle baisse
de régime ça ça se voit son visage il a
pas tous rage de iliad à mehun et dames
c3 il va se faire échanger fourrage six
grosses baisses de régime un du jour
arménien là
marie tente son va tout mais oui c'est
sa voix qui n'y croit pas lui-même il
doit vouloir tour h2 et sur d'amin avoir
froissé 2 mai aura des fous prend à f/5
way hallucinant là ce qui se passe
mais là clairement le niveau de jeu à
baisser en flèche
allah il doit ya voir damien roy ces
deux fois f53 ces trois dames trois bons
mais ça ça doit aller aussi puisque le
truc c'est que maintenant il ya le fou
qui arrive en haïti où la tour en c5
il n'y a pas vraiment de défense et la
tour c 5 ça a l'air de faire mal
il prend une fois après le fait qu'ils
jouent un maximum pour faire couler le
temps ça ça veut dire qu'il se sent pas
impérial haye qu il doit être fatigué là
là là il est il est plus dans like je
pense c'est la dernière partie et je
crois qu'il veut vraiment aller faire
une pause
dans l'air
tu en as bâti leur écrit des messages
bizarres je suis un petit peu en même
temps il écrit des messages complètement
incohérent je suis très inquiet à la je
suis très inquiet
je suis extrêmement inquiet j'ai autant
inquiet pour blake que pour ike cette
petite anglaise
je suis un peu inquiet j'ai un peu
inquiet sens
qu'y avait il écrit un truc plus plus
cohérent n'écrit plus cohérent
ni m'inquiète
de quoi
ça va c'est un coup de fil à
on va vraiment un parti qui se déroule
mardi me demande pourquoi la master
class commence pas plus tôt ça
m'inquiète un peu
j'ai un peu inquiet du coup ça fait un
fil rouge je prends le speech s
je suis très inquiet c'est plus
intéressant que le speech s il ya plus
de suspense
attendez à la villa jade m'inquiète de
ou fla
la la la la il m'inquiète de ouf je
donne 70 % qui sert classe mais je peux
me tromper
la côte je pense que master class ce
soir avec la de la côte aidé à 2,50 du
bookmaker en suédois
je parie ville soit 100 points de
chaînes donc j'allais blanc sont un peu
mieux grâce à la structure de pions mais
comme les pions doublé sont dans la sont
pas dans une majorité c'est pas trop
grave
je suivrai la la la la la cote augmente
la cote augmente
on va voir bon du coup c'est un peu
mieux pour les blancs la paire de fou
contrôle des 8 mai on va pouvoir chasser
par food et 8 ça va sans fin j'ai pas
envie dernier ce qu'il essaye de les
gagner à chaque fois et ils se comptent
ceux contre contre 400 après cette
partie on switch sur ma chaîne perso ça
c'était prévu comme ça de toute façon on
va pas faire autrement
je vais switch je vais mettre les clips
d'entrée on va voir mais je promets rien
du coup thierry w ouais kevin sfr tourbe
et des 3es foulées 6 peut-être à faux
vis ici peut pas maintenant il a protégé
la tour s'est sensiblement mieux pour
les blancs mais il a moins de temps
c'est peut-être à c'est pas mal joué
puisque fou prend ses cinq maintenant
quand il fait chaud france et 5 c sur
échec du coup c'est très bien joué
franchement tu vas prendre de la tour
parce que je passe un coup de fil
et là il ya tour d un aéronef deux cars
et le katla fou prend 1,4 pardon mais ok
peut-être des tours b 1 qui arrive
il n'ya pas cavalier e 4 3 des 720 c'est
peut-être un coup quand même 1 et tours
b un tour ces deux fois fils il peut
essayer de mettre le pion b2 sous
pression mais faut il ici la paillade
france et ce avec michael bay 3 et fois
f6 maintenant on est ok réussi à
réaliser ce plan qui n'était pas
possible de réaliser avant peut-être
être tour prend b2 prise prisa et
maintenant fou des cats je pense à
pousser trois fous ces trois fous ces
trois mais alors est-ce qu'on échange
avant ou pas avril à fait fou des 4 mai
fu c3 s'attaquer la foux prend pions
prend et lecavalier il va où il peut
aller en d2 il attaque ici mais je pense
il prend là il perd ça fout pro f 5 3 7
pouces et 8 qui a aidé 6 je pense est
maintenant à 5 à 4 le roi est dans le
carré ou pas non il est pas dans le
carré et par am qui perd n'a risqué
encore une partie dans la cadence je
crois pas mais avoir en tout cas ça
refait quatre points d'écart et non en
quatre points dans les bulles est il est
quand même assez tranquille par am qui a
raté une petite au dauphin petite
occasion eric haïk et est quand même en
en gestion dans ce match et en
réussissant à garder quatre points
d'écart avant le bullet il mène ce match
petit à petit à son terme il a une
baisse de régime mais il réussit à
rester à quatre points qui va
normalement remporter ce match
nous on va changer de chaîne va faire un
switch
on va faire un switch on va faire un
switch on va faire un switch on va faire
un switch
donc je vais faire le switch de stream
et à et je vous dirai je sais pas je
largement profité pour appeler entre
temps et on va voir ce que ça donne donc
gens voient leur aide dans quelques
secondes dès que sa part gens voient
leur aide dès que sa part et on verra du
pouce qu'on fait ce qu'on fait des bises
face on regardera la fin du match et on
verra si non on fera des beats après ou
des partis pédagogique je sais pas allez
la bascule comme france télévisions on
se